all right you can begin
good morning everyone i'm representative
michael those
and as chair of the house science
technology and energy committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to exeter executive order
2020-4
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600
or email hcs
at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting with
assisting us jennifer four our committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by
roll call vote and
we will start the meeting as we did
our last meeting by taking roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also
state whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting
which was required under the right to
know
law so representative mirner
as our acting clerk and you call the
role please
yes good morning everybody uh i may have
to leave during this meeting but
i am right now in the uh surgery unit at
dartmouth hitchcock hospital my wife's
been having surgery for the next four
hours so
uh if i get paid i'll i'll have to leave
but uh i'm just praying she's gonna be
fine
okay we all wish you the very best
uh representative thomas
present here alone in this room by
myself
nobody else representative president
president and alone representative mirna
present representative bernard
i'm already here alone sorry get you
wrong again
representative chambliss chamberlain's
president and alone
representative harrington
representative plazas bozas
i'm here and i'm alone at the moment but
my husband and son will be back soon
representative homula i
am present um i am currently alone in a
room but
everybody in my family is home so
somebody will walk through this room at
some point
representative white
i am here and i'm alone
representative sausage
yes i'm here in portsmouth in my house
uh but my wife is also in the house
somewhere so
she could be here anytime
representative callie pitts
representative callie fitz
and you asked me to speak again
sorry representative
chittenden
i think that's critien christian
representative sorry yes that is
i'm sorry excuse me i wrote down numb
things on a piece of paper because i was
at the hospital and i couldn't access it
because
it's on my pad yes representative
creation i am here i am
alone except for my dog but i don't
think she will get that right in the
next couple of weeks
no worries i hope your wife does
representative meehan
representative man
representative mcgee yes i'm here and
i'm alone
representative mcwilliams
i'm here with hubby and three kids
representative oxenham president uh
with members of the family who might
pass through during the
the time uh troy is it possible for
someone to substitute for you
after this roll call is over uh i i
could do it from home
i'm sure more easily than you can from
the hospital
yeah i'm going to stay on that they
don't feel she'll be out of surgery much
before 1 1 p.m before the doctor will
see me so
so this will give me something to do
representative partial present and i
uh have a couple of workmen in the house
representative representative pimentel
i'm president at in a room
by myself likely to stay that way
representative vincent
yes i'm here in my house in somersworth
i am in a room alone but my wife is in
another part of the house
thank you nice to see you ken happy
happy to see you
and and the chair representative votes
yes i am present i am alone at the
moment uh
i'm in a medical facility and i may have
to
be called away from time to time over
the next uh
over the course of the next two or three
hours and if i am
uh i'll signal that by turning off my
video
and uh represent representative thomas
will take over at that point
yeah i i took but before we started i
took clerk uh we did clerk training the
other day because obviously this is
going to be a unique situation with some
of the votes people will be
away from home saying whether their own
home alone or in the room
and basically what the clerk told me
that um i asked the question it's if you
have like say
you and representative thomas were in
the same room together that's
um the only time if there's another rep
in the room when we're taking executing
votes
so we have to ask that question anyways
whether or not you're
there or alone but that's the preview of
it
so representative harrington is here
he's i just saw his name pop up on my
screen yeah
he's attending via phone and he
apparently
doesn't know how to unmute himself um
as i recall on the phone you unmute
yourself with star six
is that correct jen
start six so representative harrington
try star six
and please give us a hello
i just i'm sorry representative good
morning good to see you
fred platt is here for 25 minutes before
i go to therapy
wonderfully for you
it's a long time for your therapy uh
fred yeah i'll be out of
uh i'll be out of here in the 28th home
so i'll be able to join our first
session
by zoom we will take that day by day
awesome wonderful news uh representative
fred platt uh representative harrington
did you
succeed in unmuting yourself or it may
be terrible news who knows
we're ready for the puns fred
that's why he's going to therapy
[Laughter]
so jen is there any any way we can
unmute representative harrington
it appears that he is unmuted i don't
see the
the mute symbol i am on a i'm on a zoom
meeting with the state house
on my pad gonna represent murder i think
representative harrick is calling in as
well
because he doesn't have that capability
his computer and his
he's gotta unmute his clone by star six
yeah it looks like it's unmuted so it's
possible that
that he is not connected and his
tile is just still there um
i'm not sure i could um try to reach out
to him over the phone
um and kind of troubleshoot with him if
you'd like me to
but it's the problem isn't that he's
muted
because representative harrington
doesn't have good
internet connectivity where he lives so
he's probably going to be calling in via
phone
okay and then not and he's going to want
to participate in all of our public
hearings
certainly so we're going to need to
figure this out
let me try on the side with him with the
special meeting just to see that works
yeah i'll try to give him a call and see
see what his
situation is and if he has any questions
he should be able to connect by phone
pretty easily but i can kind of run
through things with him and see if he
has
issues that we can pin down but um
like i said he may be disconnected and
this is just kind of
not catching up
okay i'm getting a text message from
he says he has he has hit star six
and you must un mute me as well
but i don't see any facility here for us
to
no and on our end it so is he hearing us
it by any chance could you ask it is the
last three digits of his number is it
i think i've heard star 4 on some phones
six nine four you said one
six nine one i'm just seeing
that number in our attendee list
um and it could be possible if he was
stuck on the attendee side that he's
hearing everything but he can't
speak
maybe it's different on a rotary dial
that presents challenges
i used to have the crank phone
so he's responding to me now let me
quickly while we're waiting for that to
happen let me quickly go over the agenda
for today
that's his home number 691
is in 691 all right let me just try this
really quickly
um and did he call in with a special
invitation
representative harrington are you on
muted
there you are yeah okay you had to do
just so with clear i can't unmute myself
it's a two-part system you have to do it
and i have to do it but
if you don't do it i don't control it i
apologize representative harrington we
thought that you were connected by
the committee because there's a tile
with your name on it
but you ended up on the attendee side so
we're we're
we're clear now i'm doing i'm watching
it but i have
i don't have a camera and i don't have
audio back and forth i can so i'm on the
phone for the audio okay
okay clear thank you thanks a lot
okay so we got that problem straightened
out and hopefully
uh next friday when we have our first
full
committee work public hearing session
starting at nine o'clock in the morning
um we'll have all these
zoom issues worked out i hope
i'm sure we'll run into others but we'll
work them out as we come across them
so there is some additional news about
zoom that happened this week
the house
staff organized
and put together a replacement
an online replacement for the pink card
and blue sheet system
that we've always used to sign people up
for
public hearings it's live
it's on the general court website and
it works pretty well um by all
appearances
and i'm going to ask jen
to give us a demonstration of
that system uh
and i see that representative kelly
pitts has her hand raised can your
question wait until after we see the
demo or
do you need to ask i just wanted to
clarify the date the meeting on the 12th
or the 11th
we're meeting on january 29th friday
january 29th january 29th
for the first year january 29th yes
okay thank you okay so
uh jen is going to give us now
a uh a walk through
of this new system and
then we'll have a few minutes for
questions afterwards probably
and then at 10 30 we're going to turn
the meeting over to the public utilities
commission
they're going to do a presentation
that'll last somewhere between an hour
and
an hour and 15 minutes and then after
that presentation is over
we're going to have a presentation by
the
four regulated or the three regulated
utilities and the
new hampshire electric co-op and that
will be the agenda for today's meeting
so i'm going to turn it over now to jen
for a demo of the
new public hearing registration system
take it away jen
all right does everybody see the home
page of the general court
okay so this is where we begin
and you want to navigate down to this
gray
box that says links to remote meetings
house remote testimony directions is
where you want to
head i apologize if you guys can hear my
pugs
snoring in the background it's a little
distracting to me right now
um so this is detailed instructions of
how to offer your testimony whether
written or um
[Music]
you know the blue sheet style so you
might want to take a look at that
in the future obviously i'm not going to
read all of this for you but it
gives instructions about raising your
hand how to testify on zoom
it also has a link here to access the
youtube channel in case
you you're someone who simply wants to
view
um the hearings
this link here takes you to what i call
the testimony portal
new hampshire house remote sign in sheet
so you start
here at the calendar so i thought we
could
use the first hearings for st e as the
example on the 29th
so you select the 29th and this drop
down box
shows all of the committees that will be
having hearings that day
and we can come here and select science
technology and energy
choose a bill just pick the first one
i am a member of the public
you would choose that you're an elected
official
representing myself if i were
representing an organization i could
insert that organization's name there
um as a nonpartisan staffer i'll choose
that i'm neutral on the bill
and you can choose whether you wish to
speak on the bill
this would create you know the pink card
version
if you don't want to speak on the bill
then you would just leave that blank
and it would be like you're offering the
blue sheet
so we can check that and then you can
see at the bottom here it gives you kind
of a summary of all the things that
you've selected so far
in case you want to change anything
the next page um
has your personal information first last
name
phone and email address
and then you have an opportunity to
verify that
information um on the final page
representative votes when you get the
readout you'll know that i don't really
want to testify on this
bill and then finally it tells you
thank you for registering to testify at
two o'clock on hb 264.
please email written testimony and
documents you wish to share with the
committee to house science technology
and energy
at lege.nh.us so anyone who has written
documents to submit
they will use that email address um
and compose an email that will go to
everyone
on the committee plus the committee
assistant
um and then finally tech help
numbers are listed at the bottom
and then you can go back to the start
so i'll stop the share and then if
anybody has questions i'm happy to take
them
representative oxenoum oh will sponsors
and co-sponsors be uh required to
provide written testimony
24 hours in advance also
we're going to require written testimony
from everyone
i know we won't get it from everyone but
we're going to ask everyone to submit
written testimony and
one of the reasons written testimony is
going to be so critical is because
if we schedule an hour for a public
hearing and
there aren't enough minutes in that hour
to accommodate everybody who wants to
speak
their written testimony will
substitute for their inability to submit
verbal testimony so that's why we're
going to encourage it
of everyone
all right representative mcgee
um mr chairman i just had a question
it's more logistical
uh it sounds like if folks submit
written testimony online that we'll each
get that as a blast in email
so we'll just have to keep track of that
in advance of our
our hearing days but um
how will the compilation of who's
testifying at the hearing come in how is
that going to be
ordered and scheduled and all that stuff
i mean once you have the sponsor speak
is there going to be a printout that
goes to you
to know for each hearing who's who's
coming up for testimony or
because usually you do it with the cards
but i'm just curious
when will when will you know how many
people are scheduled to testify because
that
would affect how long the hearings would
be scheduled for wouldn't it it's like a
um before the horse kind of thing
wouldn't that give us an indication of
maybe how long a hearing would require
jen i believe it's about 30 minutes
before the hearing that we are planning
on
producing that list of of speakers who
have registered so far
um so that'll give like you said the
chair an opportunity to see
um how much interest there is and help
him understand
how much time to limit each speaker to
so is it going to be a hard and fast
rule that someone can't just come at the
last minute and get their name on the
list
because you had said that before but i
just curious
that that's the case
i think that will be within the chairs
discretion
well the way the system that jen just
demonstrated works
is that if you register
before 30 minutes before the hearing
starts
then we'll be notified but if you
register after or
less than 30 minutes before the hearing
starts we won't get notified
now if you're an attendee and you
request to testify because at the end of
the testimony i will ask
is there anyone else who would like to
testify and if someone
who is an attendee raises their hands
and says
i would like to testify then we will
promote them
to be able to do so
if we have time if we don't we'll
suggest that they submit
a written some written testimony
but we'll try to accommodate as many
people as we can
uh and you're right uh representative
mcgee
if during the sign up period
on a on a given bill if we get a number
of people
signing up to testify that indicate one
hour isn't going to be enough
then we may have to make adjustments to
the length of the hearing as
before we conduct it so we'll have to
play that by ear
mr chair primary go ahead representative
thomas
yes uh thank you i just want to
reiterate what
uh what uh chairman votes said last week
that the timing allowed for the speakers
is so critical this year and i know that
people who have been on the committee
before
know that we have perennial visitors
that speak
that love to speak and so it's very
critical that every member gets the word
out to
their supporters or people that they
know
that they must just stick to the basic
facts of the bill and dispense with
verbios historical data
and rhetorical information
that just takes up time but doesn't add
to the bill
that could be put into the written
testimony so we ask people to please
reiterate that the timing is critical
and to stick with their main point
or a couple of main points that they
need to highlight
in their written testimony otherwise
we're not going to get through our time
and it's going to create a lot of
problems so we we
ask that you get this information out
and for anyone who's listening
to please do the same thank you
we have to always keep in mind that
we are going to be restricted to one
public hearing day per week
we almost lost our day for next week
because we are scheduled normally to
have our meetings on mondays
but there wasn't enough time to notice a
meeting
properly in the calendar for next monday
so the speaker was gracious enough to
juggle the schedule a little bit to
allow us to have a friday
next week otherwise we would have missed
next week altogether
which would have put us potentially
behind schedule already so we're lucky
to be able to meet next friday
and hopefully with that and our one week
a day
schedule starting monday february 1st
we'll be able to get through all these
bills
before the deadlines
of march 11th
so are there any further questions about
the
pink card blue sheet registration
process
and the sign up for uh for bills
are there any general questions uh
about our process uh
going forward because we're gonna get
started a week from today
if there's anything you need to know
about
how we're gonna do what we're going to
do either ask it now
or get in touch with me offline sometime
between now and next friday
and we'll try to get all your questions
answered so that we can get started
uh next friday right on time
there's a question from the attendance
ken uh go ahead
thank you mr chairman i do have a
question i've heard from
a couple members that um we may uh
choose to in just a clarification we may
choose to be on zoom
or we may go to the legislative office
building is that true
ah you just muted yourself
you just yeah you're still on mute yep
yes that is true then we're restricted
to one
day a week is because
i'm going to use the legislative office
building for public hearings
uh for community days mondays correct
ours is going to be monday but the the
reason we're limited so much is because
we're only able to have two committees
meeting
on each floor per day all right so
that's that's only four committees in
the
legislative office building per day
so that means you can't meet more than
once a week
in order for all the companies to get a
day
i was just questioning i have been uh i
have got the series of shots
so i am fortunate not that it makes me
uh invincible but i just
thank you for that information you're
welcome thank you
representative kelly fitz don't forget
mute yourself
you're unmuted go ahead just wondering
about
we still have the same committee room
302 and do we have a committee phone
number
no we're actually meeting in 202 203.
so we'll be on the second floor instead
of on the third floor where we were
have been in previous years um
i don't know if that's a permanent
assignment or a temporary sign and i'm
not sure but
that's where our first meeting is
jen do you know anything about that i'm
not sure if
the rooms are going to necessarily stay
the same all the time or not
it is my understanding that when you
check in with security
when you arrive if you if you choose to
come in person
that there should be a list there that
will let you know which room to go to on
that day
my follow-up is because i wanted to buy
business cards
order business cards don't know which
room to put and don't know what
contacted the state house phone number
to use
we do apologies i raised my hand i've
got to leave for physical therapy
and do apologies to the puc bye
and thank you for the cards and prayers
good luck with your
good luck your therapy great just your
friend
okay did did you get the rest of the
question
no i didn't fred interrupted uh please
repeat it
well it was just because i'm looking to
buy new business cards and don't have a
room number or a state house contact
number
and that i think is kind of important
okay i'll uh i'll ask the uh speaker's
office
what we should do about that and get you
in
uh if i may uh mr chair i would imagine
this whole setup is uh expected to
go away for the second year of our
session and so
i'm sure that when that happens we will
go back to our normal
room number so uh you can verify that
but i would suspect that you're if
you're going to have cards made up
i would stick to our normally assigned
room number when we
all can go back into that building
anyway
okay uh representative
jd bernardi and uh
are you going to be around for this
entire session because
i'd like to get us started with our
presentations
out of fairness to the presenters um
so if you could hold your question till
afterwards
it goes to the question about the room
number and the phone number
if you look on the uh if you look in the
in the list of committees
where it specifies who the members are
in that uh designation there for every
committee it lists our room numbers 304
and
our phone numbers 271-3369
so i think that's what's been assigned
yes i'll get verification on that and i
appreciate you
looking that up i appreciate that so for
the purpose of ordering business cards
we may continue to use the old room
number but i'll get verification of that
so let's move on now and turn the
program over to the
public utilities commission i uh
don't have the list right in front of me
i'm not sure who the first speaker
is but um whoever that might
be i'm going to turn the floor over to
you so please
take it away
i've promoted mr shulock
um and mr shulock just let us know
um which members you'd like to join you
or if you'd like me to move everyone in
mr sherlock you are live with the
committee
good morning this is david shula can you
hear me yes okay
good it took me a second to figure it
out um
and i think we may present you with one
of your first technological challenges
because we would like to put up a
powerpoint
and there should be somebody online uh
by the name
of corinne lemay okay
who um would want to control the
powerpoint and then if it's possible to
still see us speak that would be great
okay i've just promoted is there anyone
else from the puc that you'd like me to
promote at this time mr shulock
uh do you want to promote them all at
once or as we go
it's up to you whatever you think is
best um why don't we
um uh promote everybody and that way
when i introduce them they can wave
their hands so that you can see who they
are
okay okay so okay is live now
i have given you permission to share
your screen so you should
should be good to go
so while she's doing that my name is
david shulock for those of you
who don't know me and some of you may
not recognize me because i grew a
coveted beard
i'm the general counsel at the public
utilities commission
and um one of the features of my
position is that along with my
assistant michelle bunnemeyer
i coordinate the commission's
legislative
support efforts so i'm a point of
primary contact
for all of you if you have questions
about
how a bill operates or what the
commission's position on a bill might be
you should always feel comfortable
contacting me
sometimes um and then actually you
should probably contact me
uh first if you need to talk to someone
at the pdc about a bill that you're
working on
um i may be able to answer the question
for you uh
right off the bat and i promise i will
not act as a roadblock i will make sure
that
uh you're put in touch with uh the
person or the team at the puc uh
that that can help you um
most often uh the the person that you
really
will want to speak with will be one of
the people who are presenting today
um and um i have some contact
information on one of the slides for
for three of us but if you find yourself
working on a bill
uh with a particular person who's come
to testify you should also feel free to
call them directly
so um uh we've put together a
presentation for you today
uh i call it the tip of the iceberg
presentation
um um our uh chairwoman
diane martin will give you a brief
overview of the pucs
jurisdiction and the types of things
that we work on
commissioner bailey who also serves as
the state's nesco manager
will give an overview of regional
electricity issues
and then five of our directors will talk
to you about
the the areas where they're
they're sort of responsible
and so if i can enter
well i don't see other people to be able
to introduce them so
why don't we go ahead and um move on to
our first presenter who is
uh diane martin our chairwoman
okay good morning everyone can you hear
me
yes excellent
good morning chairman vos members of the
committee my name is diane martin and i
serve as the chairwoman of the public
utilities commission
in addition i also serve as the
chairwoman of the site evaluation
committee
and i have recently been elected to
serve as the chair of the nuclear
decommissioning
financing committee when treasurer bill
dwyer
retired it has been a busy year
at the puc i fill the role
on the commission as the practicing
attorney who has to be admitted to the
new hampshire bar
i don't know many of you from my my
prior work and for those of you who
don't know me
before joining the commission i had the
honor of serving as associate attorney
general
and chief of staff at the department of
justice
during my years there i served as a
litigator and an advisor to nearly every
state agency
i'm also a mother of four children and i
have a farm in deerfield new hampshire
where i usually start my day pretty
early in the morning feeding cows
chickens and horses and in the summer
you'll find me
driving my tractor hang my fields
i do want to preface my remarks today
about the commission work
by reminding everyone that the
commission and its staff
is required by law to abstain from
public comment
about matters pending before the
commission
we'll do our best to answer any
questions you have and we will rely on
our council to jump in and keep us on
track if we're heading in the wrong
direction
okay so if we go to the slides and start
with the org chart
you'll see that the commission oh
ryan can you go to the order chart
there we go all right thank you you'll
see that the chair of the commission has
a dual role so it is
part of the three member commission
that is the regulatory body it is also
the agency head for the
agency that supports the work of that
body
so what do we do at the commission the
mission gives you a really good idea of
what our responsibilities are
and the mission of the commission very
important one
it involves making sure that we all have
the electricity
gas water and sewer that we need and
that it's provided to us in a safe
manner that we can rely on
and importantly that it comes at a price
that's just and reasonable
the commission also has a very important
role as arbiter
between the interests of the public who
purchase the services
also known as the ratepayers or
customers and the businesses who provide
those utility services to us
it sounds simple but it's not it's an
incredibly
complex challenge trying to serve as the
arbiter of those two interests
importantly we make sure that the voice
of the right player is always heard
i want to spend a few moments
recognizing the amount of work done
by the commission and its staff before
joining the public utilities commission
i did not appreciate the amount of work
that is done at the commission and i
think most
members of the public really have no
idea how much goes on there
so if we can turn to the slides yes
there we go so dockets for fiscal year
we opened 181 dockets in the various
utilities subject matter from electric
to some
sustainable natural gas water and sewer
telecommunications and other that's 180
dockets that actually had to be opened
for decision making purposes
out of those we had a number of orders
that were issued
i apologize i'm trying to catch up with
your slides
here we go uh total in fiscal year 20 of
112. i think that's one of the things i
really
did not understand was the volume of
decisions coming out of the commission
and the amount of work that it takes to
get to that point there's all the
preliminary work done
to investigate gather information that
staff puts in hours and hours and hours
to work on
and then there are the public hearings
public comments
and finally the decision decision-making
process all of which culminates in an
order being issued
it's it's a significant amount of work
another point that i think people don't
realize is that
the commission provides customer service
to so many
of the residents of the state of new
hampshire if you look at the
slide on inquiries made to the consumer
division
there were nearly 5 000 inquiries
during fiscal year 20. and those require
some
member of the staff to take a call
answer questions perhaps
get back to them several times so
there's a lot of work involved
with all of that to accomplish all of
this work the commission has 73
full-time positions
and a number of those are vacant at this
point in time
that work has been made even more
challenging by the kobe pandemic
just three short months after i joined
the puc the pandemic began the mission
has worked
really hard to serve the public without
interruption despite the
pandemic we've made several changes to
make that possible
including providing web enabled remote
hearings
technical sessions and meetings just
like you're doing here today
that way members of the public can still
participate even if they are not able to
come out because of the pandemic
suspended rules so that filing of paper
copies
doesn't have to be done so that you can
do everything electronically
and that helps to keep things running
without people needing to come to the
commission
and we've waived paper application
requirements for certain programs so
that
members of the public who are applying
can submit those applications
electronically we also updated our web
page
so that um it directs members of the
public to
whatever information they're looking for
related to what we're doing
during povid finally and probably most
importantly
we have opened a number of
investigations to gather information
from the utilities from members of the
public
from the businesses that have been
impacted so that we can have a better
understanding of how the pandemic
is actually impacting um all of those
folks
and and use that for our work
in conclusion i really want to point out
that the amount of work that the staff
at the commission does
the work in accomplishing the admission
the mission of the
commission is incredibly important it's
broad
and it's varied it covers a wide range
of topics from energy efficiency
to rate making the commission handles
cases that run the gamut from a simple
half hour
public meeting to cases that go on for
days
involve very significant legal issues
that are very very important to the
people of this state
importantly as i said before it involves
a significant amount of customer service
taking calls from the citizens of new
hampshire helping to
resolve their issues it involves the
important work of administering
sustainable
energy programs and the vital safety
work related to the gas pipelines in the
state
as well as dig safe in inspections and
investigations
to make sure our utilities are provided
safely
that work is complex and challenging and
requires legal
financial and energy expertise
the staff of the commission is comprised
of a group of experts
who are economists engineers accountants
auditors lawyers and analysts as well as
an
incredible support staff who all work
together to make
sure that the commission is able to
perform all of its duties
it has been an honor to join that team
this year
i want to thank you all for giving us
this opportunity to speak today
and i am happy to take questions at any
time
okay okay um not seeing any questions
our
next presenter is randy nefer the
director of our safety division
hello can everybody hear me and see me
yes great thank you
uh as david said uh my name is randy
nepper i've been with the
commission for about 16 years now
i've spent uh all my adult life in the
energy field either working for
you utility a manufacturer of energy
consulting role for environmental
in the last 16 years of the commission
here so
i saw earlier on the slide deck or maybe
i didn't see it yet
i can't remember um we do have the
arbiter role the commission
is rsa 363 17.
but i point to uh rsa 374.1
which has to deal with the general
duties of utilities
and that's the one that says every
public utility shall furnish such
service and facilities
shall be reasonably safe adequate and in
all other respects just and reasonable
so that was written about 110 years ago
by new hampshire legislators and i think
it's still
appropriate today and i want to call
your attention that the first qualifier
that they used is the word safe and so i
think that
that order in which they listed it is
worthy of attention
and so that becomes our number one job
is safe service
so um basically the legislators
just defined our mission at the safety
division and so
um i will go with um how we divvy up
that mission task on slide 17.
so slide 17 shows the six areas of
responsibility we're
primarily involved with the safety
division in my mind is the
technical discipline or engineering
aspect
portion of the of utility service is
what we concentrate on
so we try to maintain the expertise
needed within the commission to assist
in the review of those kind of issues
that affect design or operations
maintenance emergency response
training or other areas that lead to
safe systems
the six areas of responsibility that we
have are
i think diane alluded to it is uh
digsafe
calling 8-1-1 before you put a shovel in
the ground
hopefully those are terms everybody's
aware of
we administer and enforce the
underground damage prevention rules of
the state
and 95 percent of our expenses in doing
that are supported by two federal grants
that law has been in existence since
1983 and i think our one of our programs
one of the best
uh in the united states our ratio of
damages to notifications
is one half the average of the united
states and i think we're in the top
five or six in the country for states
that do that
we do it by performing outreach and
education
we do field investigations and then we
also act as the enforcement agent and
yeah we do issue some civil penalties
when warranted
all civil penalties do go to the state's
general fund
that takes about 150 to 200 cases a year
and then most of those result in the puc
providing training to excavators
so that they will not damage utilities
in the future and
try to keep our incident levels down the
second area where
we work on is pipeline safety and we
conduct about 250 to 300 inspections per
year
that equates to about 200 person days
and we look at
field inspections procedural inspections
record inspections
and in 2020 2020
um that led to about a dozen compliance
actions
uh involving about 50 violations of
either state or
federal regulations and that area about
70 percent of our expenditures
are supported by federal funds and our
inspectors are required to take
a vast amount of educational courses
they take 16 different one-level
one-week level courses by the federal
government
given by the usdot so they really become
subject matters
experts in pipeline safety the third
area that we focus on is electric safety
and reliability
we're one of the few new england states
that does a lot of electrical
safety inspections we've just kind of uh
started and
improved that in the last year in 2020
we have a new inspector that's doing
that
and then we also investigate and report
any
contacts and uh deaths or fatalities to
see if we can find
things that need improvement so um
we're uh uh we're eager to get that
program um mature and
uh it's working out very well so far so
fourth area that we work on is emergency
preparedness
so we review the emergency preparedness
of our utilities so we look at their
emergency plans and review them we
participate in drills with
them but then we also have a double role
where we
are acting as the
subject matter expert for the state and
implementing their emergency response
plan
so we do that in two sectors we do that
in the communications and energy sector
and so we assist the homeland security
when there's a natural disaster or
anytime they open up their
eoc we're there to help out with any
efforts that they need
uh the fourth and fifth area that we
work on
is uh engineering and gis for the
commission
so we have a pretty extensive gis
system that we communicate with the
utilities on
where their facilities are and that's
pretty voluntarily with the commission
it works pretty well
that gives us some of the background
information to be able to conduct our
inspections but it gives us the overall
critical knowledge that we need on their
infrastructure
and then the last area that we focus on
is uh security and uh
security uh comprises of both physical
security
and now cyber security and cyber
security is kind of
um on the forefront of everybody's mind
um in december of 2020
the u.s was probably had its largest
attack
on cyber security that affected
both private industry and government and
the
effects of that attack are still being
uh um
investigated now and so um
we believe that's a role that's going to
continue to grow at the puc
um and as our adversaries
want to disrupt the way we do life um
attacking our infrastructure and
especially energy
is one way to do that and so that's
requiring more focus of the commission
so
that role is growing and on one of the
slide that's right before it
is just some of the statistics that i
talked about in a graphical form
so with that i think i will
turn it over to the next slides unless
there's any particular questions people
have on safety
uh excuse me this is uh peter sampsit uh
i don't know exactly how i can ask a
question can i raise my hand i don't see
any raised hand
icon right now or
what mr chairman
representative some stitch if if you
press the participants button at the
bottom of your screen
yeah you just need to pop up again to
access the raised hand and
it is best to use that function right
now since
the screen is limited i do that and i
don't see a raised hand anymore because
all i see is the list of the
participants
oh i'm sorry yeah if i look at the
panelists
yes then i see a raised hand okay thank
you very much for that
information and i i actually i
okay i i would like to raise my hand to
ask a question of uh diane
of miss martin if i could
okay go ahead uh just as a clarification
for all of us who aren't lawyers
can you please just give us a brief
definition of what is a docket
and what is an order and how long do
these things take normally to uh
complete yes so
a dock is uh when we have
an issue come up or an investigation or
something that rises to the level of
meeting
of proceeding and so that's sort of the
typical thing you think of where
there may be a hearing a number of
hearings those are dockets
um orders are what comes out at the end
of a docket generally speaking and so
that's the written document
that documents the decision of the
commission
and how long does this take
it it really depends upon the topic
that's
involved in the docket so typically a
rate case
is a year-long process by statute
other other cases are shorter there may
be investigations
that can go on for a long period of time
that involve stakeholders and are more
geared toward
gathering information and then you'll
have multiple dockets related to those
so
it really does depend upon the topic
okay thank you very much you're welcome
i have a quick question for mr
shulock mr shulock
are there time constraints on
participation of
the php in this presentation and if so
we restrict asking questions till the
end
or possibly not ask questions at all
[Music]
i think the commissioners have a hearing
at
one o'clock um
they're the only uh people i think who
have to leave right um
and uh we've designed it so that their
presentations are
early in the process so um
i i think you can feel comfortable
asking questions
as we go along if you'd like and that's
probably better
for the commissioners who do have that
time constraint
if you ask them their questions now okay
thank you for that clarification
representative plozas
yes ms martin
um if you could through you
uh this civil
on page 13 of your presentation
you showed the amounts of dockets and
there was a decrease for 19 and 20 is
there a reason for that
and then was there something that
affected yeah
thank you
um i will defer i think probably to
um mr shulock to answer that because i
actually
joined at the end of 2019 but my sense
is that the work
while always intense ebbs and flows to a
certain extent and really depends in
part upon
for example right now we have a number
of rate cases
a lot of the utilities have come in for
rate changes
and and sometimes there can be a a
period of time between those so
it's somewhat unpredictable but um
david do you have a response as to kind
of the past
i think i can say that the volume has
gone up
since deregulation uh because we have
um that's volume of dockets that's not
necessarily
work but the the dockets are of a
different type
um that happened a number of years ago
the rest of it i think is explained uh
one by um sometimes you task us
with dockets that we have to open right
and resolve within a certain period of
time that can change the number
um and then otherwise it's really just
the ebb and flow that
uh the chairwoman discussed uh we don't
actually direct utilities when to bring
in cases they bring them in as they
really as they see fit so we're sort of
subject to that evidence flow
yes if i could clarify could we go to um
the powerpoint 13. i think my question
was on that one
i thought it was dockets
there was a lowering an amount of
we'll wait till we get there
corinne can you go through each there
you go
um
no it must been the 11. the inquiries um
it was lower in the last three years
what are inquiries thank you
so these are this slide reflects calls
coming into the commission or or emails
coming in
from members of the public about
concerns
and amanda noonan our director of that
division is actually here today so
if she would like to jump in and explain
further that's fine
sure good good morning representatives
um so part of the reason
for the decreasing
made by sector uh has confused
economic conditions regarding the
pandemic
the governor's say on disconnections of
utility servant
people being focused on other
conservatives
in their day-to-day lives they're not
necessarily their utility bills
so that attributed finding calls and
plenty
hunting
through you mr chair thank you ms known
representative thomas do you have a
question
yes briefly and uh primarily for the
benefit of the freshman but mine as well
if a representative has
would like to speak before the puc about
something that is happening
in their district but they are perhaps
not um affected by what's going on
directly in other words if their
property is not being affected by what's
going on
say a particular project coming coming
through the area would they still be
able to speak
before the puc or do they have to go
through the um
a more formal process
to to recognize if they're qualified to
speak or not
thank you representative um so we hear
actually frequently from legislators as
public comment and so we do take public
comment
and invite that in most cases so that's
always an opportunity for anyone
who may not have standing on the
particular underlying issue
we take it in writing we take it at
hearings
and we try to provide the opportunity
thank you
okay no more questions so let's move on
amanda that's you
okay thank you david and good morning
again representatives
my name is amanda noonan and i am the
director of the commission's consumer
services and
external affairs division um we just
talked a little bit about the analysts
in the consumer affairs division
working with utility customers utilities
and other stakeholders resolving
concerns
and providing information related to
utility service
in addition to that work the division
also assists
um well in addition to assisting
customers in providing education the
division also oversees the electric
assistance program
thank you corinne the electric
began in 2002 and it's provided bill
assistance to more than 402 000
households in new hampshire
since it was first rolled out in 2002.
the program is funded through the low
income portion of the system benefits
charge it's set at 1.5 mils per kilowatt
hour which is less than one dollar
per month on a 625 kilowatt hour bill
house co holds with incomes at or below
60 of new hampshire state median income
are eligible to apply for assistance
through the program
applications are taken by the community
action agencies
and the eap eligibility criteria
mirrors that of the fuel assistance
program so that applications for both
programs
can be completed simultaneously by
a consumer making the process easier for
them
streamlining the process and giving both
programs some administrative
efficiencies the discounts range
from eight percent to 76 percent
with households with the lowest incomes
as a percentage of the federal poverty
guidelines
receiving the highest discount on their
bill
next slide please karen
as you can see from this chart um it
just kind of provides you
with a breakdown of
what the incomes for these households
look like
so for example a household of four
the maximum income that household could
earn and still be eligible for the
program
is sixty nine thousand six hundred and
eighty six dollars
that's sixty percent of the state median
income in new hampshire for a family of
four
a family of four with an income less
than or equal to nineteen thousand eight
hundred and seventy five dollars
would be eligible for the seventy six
percent discount on the monthly bill
however the family of four with an
income between thirty nine thousand
seven hundred and fifty dollars and the
upper limit of 69
686 would receive a discount of 8
percent
on its monthly bill
next slide please
the average benefit over the past five
years
for households on the electric
assistance program has been a little
over
37 a month or about 450 dollars a year
and you can see here um
what it's been year by year there are
currently approximately
thirty thousand eight hundred households
receiving assistance through the program
the participation is
fairly evenly spread between each
discount tier
there are 18 of the households are in
the 76
tier 19 and a half are in the 52
discount tier 18
are in the 36 discount tier
16 in the 22 discount tier
almost 30 percent are in the 8 discount
tier and that is the wise
range in income so not surprisingly more
households wind up
in that discount tier than the others
next slide please
so competitive energy supply um the
consumer services division is also
directly involved with issues related to
competitive electric
energy suppliers as part of the
restructuring of the electric industry
which occurred
in the late 1990s and early 2000s 2001
customers of the four electric utilities
can now choose to purchase their
electric
energy supply from someone other than
the
their utility they remain a customer of
their utility
as the utility continues to deliver the
energy to the homes and businesses
and is responsible for restoring service
when there's a power outage
and tom franz will talk a little bit
later but those utilities are now really
called
electric distribution companies because
they're distributing the energy
and they're not the sole provider of the
energy itself
the commission hosts a comparison
shopping page on its website
which allows customers to compare the
products and prices of competitive
energy suppliers
to the default energy service that they
could purchase through their utility
the information on the website is
maintained by the suppliers and the
utilities
suppliers are required to update their
information monthly
or more frequently as it changes utility
default service prices
change twice a year so that's when you
would see the change in the utility
energy service price
in addition to the comparison shopping
page there's also a considerable
considerable amount of information on
the commission's website
to help consumers in evaluating offers
from competitive suppliers
and to determine whether competitive
energy supply choice is right for them
next slide please
so migration to competitive energy
supply
not surprisingly is very high for large
commercial and industrial customers
that was the first group of customers to
move from utility energy service to
competitive energy service
and it continues to be the case today
that far more
cni customers purchase their energy
supply from a competitive supplier than
do small commercial
or residential customers as a result
you see the um the overall customers
taking competitive supply when you look
at
the utility may be relatively low for
example for eversource
only 21 of customers take competitive
energy supply
that's 56 of their total sales though so
you can see how the c and i
load skews that those two figures
next slide please
although the commission doesn't regulate
the products and prices offered by
competitive suppliers
competitive electric power suppliers
must register with the commission
commissions adopted rules governing the
registration requirements which include
financial security to protect
customers in the event of a default or
some other harmful behavior to consumers
the rules also focus on important
consumer protection requirements
which include things like disclosure
regarding the terms of service
disclosure regarding pricing fixed
pricing variable pricing
notification about what happens or
notification prior to the contract end
a certain period of time prior to the
contract end
to notify customers about what's going
to happen and what they need to do next
if they wish to continue with the
supplier discontinue
do something different the rules also
establish requirements for those
suppliers who wish to undertake
door-to-door sales next slide please
um last i just point you to two great
resources
um there was a question about what's a
docket and what's in order
the commission's website you can follow
you can go to our website and
find information about dockets you can
access valuable information
about consumer proceedings orders and
rules
our twitter account will alert you to
when orders are issued
when new proceedings are opened
both great ways to follow what's
happening at the commission
and with that i'll turn it over to our
next speaker which i believe is
commissioner bailey
good morning chairman votes members of
the committee can everybody hear me
can you hear me yes okay thank you
i'm kate bailey the other commissioner
at the public utilities commission
i uh by training him an engineer
and so i'm going to start telling you a
little bit about electricity
uh my role another role that i
play is that of nesco manager a job
representative harrington knows well and
held with with distinction
nesco is an abbreviation for the new
england states committee
on energy each new england state
has an esco manager appointed by the
governor
governor sununu appointed me to the
position in 2017.
in that capacity i work with regional
colleagues to advance our common
interests in the provision of
electricity
at the lowest prices over the long term
while maintaining reliable service and
environmental quality
we share an integrated power system or
grid with the other new england states
as you probably heard the other day iso
new england coordinates and runs the
system
this graphic represents a simplified
diagram of the system
on the left side of the dotted line you
see a power plant or generator
a substation and transmission lines
that's the system the iso operates and
ferc regulates
the costs associated with that represent
of our electricity bills on the
on the right side of the line you see
the distribution system delivering
electricity to residential and
commercial customers that's the part of
the system the commission regulates
nesco works on the cost drivers
regulated by ferc
the cost drivers behind wholesale
electricity rates include energy
capacity and transmission among other
things but those are the primary
cost drivers energy is generated by
power plants
to meet the demand for electricity at a
certain moment in time
the cost fluctuates every five minutes
and is mostly based on the cost of fuel
capacity is what we pay generators to
make sure we have enough capability
to generate the amount of energy needed
at the peak demand
generators like merrimack get a capacity
payment but only generate energy on the
coldest or hottest days
when demand is very high without the
capacity payment
it would be uneconomic for merrimack to
stick around to operate only a few days
a year
when it operates it also gets energy
payments
transmission carries electricity from
where it's generated to where it's
needed
as generators get located farther away
from where electricity is used
like offshore wind in the ocean wind
turbines on a remote hill
or solar farms in rural areas we will
need to add more transmission
to deliver the electricity to load
centers
next slide please this graph shows how
much we pay for each of those components
as you can see the cost of energy has
come down as gas prices have decreased
capacity fluctuates as power plants
retire
and new cloud power plants get built
capacity prices are set
three years in advance to give resources
the time to build
last year the winning bid for capacity
cost for three years into the future
was at an all-time low so capacity costs
will go down over the next three years
transmission costs on the other hand
have increased and will likely to
continue to do so
each of the five other new england
states have passed laws
to significantly reduce economy-wide
carbon emissions by mid-century
that means not only the power sector
will have to reduce emissions but the
transportation and building sectors
must reduce emissions as well as people
move to electric vehicles and electric
heat pumps
electricity demand will increase and we
will have to add additional clean
generating resources
as nesco manager i am guided by new
hampshire rsa 374
f8 which directs that we work to prevent
or minimize the rate impact of other
states policies
last year the governors of connecticut
maine massachusetts rhode island and
vermont
issued a joint statement calling for
deep decarbonization in the region
the other state's laws will will have an
impact on new hampshire
as a result i worked with my regional
colleagues to draft the new england
state's vision statement
through that work the other states
understand and agree that new hampshire
customers should not
and will not pay for the policies
implemented by those states
the vision statement focused on three
areas that need reform
first a market-based approach needs to
be developed
that will recognize clean energy
generators necessary to satisfy state
mandates
we have an agreement that that market
will be designed
to ensure that consumers in any one
state do not fund the
public policy requirements mandated by
another state's laws
second we need to plan transmission not
only to satisfy reliability as is the
approach now
but to use the current transmission
system more efficiently
and plan a transmission grid in the
least cost way
that will accommodate the shift in the
location of generation
farther away from where electricity is
used
again the other states have agreed that
such planning is not intended to modify
the state's agreement
that consumers in one state don't fund
the policy requirements
of another state's laws third we will be
looking to ice up to
iso governance under the current system
unlike the generators and transmission
owners
states do not have a vote on the rules
iso puts in place on these important
issues
these are major changes and the region
is holding technical forms to solicit
input and educate as many people as
possible
about these issues we held the first
virtual forum on january 13th and i
believe over 200 people attended
at that forum each state explained its
policy on carbon emissions
and then kneepool who has voting rights
on what the iso does
and the iso presented explanations on
what each of those organizations do
a recording of that session will be
posted on the new england
energyvision.com
website if you'd like to register for
any of the other forums or follow all
information on these topics check out
that website
very quickly i'd like to introduce you
to one market solution i think has
great potential it's called the forward
clean energy market
or fcem the idea is to create a market
for clean energy attributes
states who have mandates for clean
energy would purchase their required
quantity of clean energy from that
market
new hampshire could purchase a quantity
of zero and would therefore not pay for
other states requirements
i believe this is a much better solution
than carbon pricing
which would raise the price of energy
and shift costs to new hampshire
a market-based solution would likely
provide a more cost-effective solution
than long-term contracts which in my
experience always
end up costing more finally if new
hampshire law changes
the market would be available for new
hampshire to purchase clean energy
attributes
this solution is not as simple as it
sounds there are many details to be
worked out
but for now it seems to be the most
promising way to satisfy differing state
laws
sharing a regional power system i'm
happy to take questions if anyone has
them
or we can move on to
representative kelly pitts i know you
had a question before do you still have
one
i think you're on mute
well i wish a lot of people had that
button i bet
uh when we talk about the states that
new hampshire not paying
can you explain what the cost will be
share the cost such as the nine percent
or the nine point four percent i think
it is now
that new hampshire pays for out of state
projects could you just
briefly explain that sure
new hampshire pays for energy capacity
and transmission as a re that's part of
a regional
system so the price for energy
is is set for the region
and if if for example we
we had a carbon adder to the price of
energy the price of energy would go up
and everybody in the region would pay
this would pay that price
now there are there are ideas to
allow clean energy resources to keep
that high price
and carbon emitters to pay it back and
then it gets reallocated to the states
but
it would still increase the amount of
the energy cost for new hampshire
customers because of other state
policies
another um part that we share
that you mentioned is the cost of
transmission and
transmission costs are divided among the
region based on
load and so new hampshire
has 9.4 percent of the region's load so
we get allocated 9.4 percent of the
region's transmission costs
so that's why the agreement with the
other states
to um not
modify our overall agreement that
states without policy without clean
energy policies shouldn't have to pay
for
for the cost of other states policies um
is very relevant for transmission
because as i mentioned
we're going to have to build more
transmission to get the energy
from the ocean to the load center
and that's not going to be cheap and so
one of the things that i'm working on as
an esco manager is to figure out a way
to allocate that fairly
thank you
any other questions if not next speaker
okay i see representative mcgee go ahead
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman um thank you for
coming to speak with us this morning
um commissioner bailey um
my question i think is a follow-on to
that in that
we have discussions ongoing about
various policies that are coming through
our committee in terms of um
load reducers uh in the in the clean
energy sector and how you know where
they belong in our energy picture
and i i wonder if you could tell us
anything about
the new hampshire electric energy
picture
right now and whether there would be a
positive impact
from greater local generation
so that we wouldn't have to
be be leveraging all of that load
towards some large capacity generator
like the offshore wind that you were
speaking of
in other words it what's the benefit to
us having
um higher penetration in local
generation i guess that's the question
like distributed energy resources yep
okay
um distributed energy resources can
reduce
the load that um
that the region has to serve with
uh the other generators so
that would let me think about this that
would uh
reduce demand
for it could possibly reduce demand for
the total capacity that we have to buy
and um it would
lower the amount of energy that we um
actually i think i need to jump in here
because
we do have open dockets on the value of
that
distributed generation both in terms to
the system
and to pricing i'm not certain that
commissioner bailey is the appropriate
person
to answer those questions thank you
great general counsel i guess
probably no one should
point well taken
okay thank you representative mcgee
representative thomas
yes thank you mr chair um along that
same line
i have a little more general question so
you bring the point out about
we're going to have to put more
transmission lines in for
whatever new projects we do such as
offshore wind
or any other wind or even perhaps solar
so i guess my question would be is
when we have policy bills coming in
that want to that would encourage
expansion of these programs
should there not be a
during testimony should there not be
information provided
as to what the estimates of the cost of
transmission
prices that that may rise because of
that and therefore it's a kind of a
cost balancing system to see we we put
more of this
energy in but we're going to have to pay
more for transmission
and what kind of cost might that we
might be expected to pay
would that be possible information that
could be provided that could be provided
uh during testimony
i think it would be really hard to uh
provide
factual information about the cost of
the transmission
i think that's an important question and
um but it the cost will depend on so
many variables
where the uh energy the news energy
source is going to be located
whether there is existing transmission
that can handle that
so um that's one of the things that the
new england
energy vision is trying to
work at work on is is to plan for
transmission um under
various scenarios so uh assuming
by 2030 we have to have x amount of
um clean energy resources and we know
that they're going to be located
in location a b and c what's the cost of
transmission going to be
and we don't do that kind of planning
now because iso
is um in charge of trans in charge of
transmission planning
and um their mission is to
absolutely make sure the lights don't go
out so their mission isn't really about
least cost so
that's one of the things that we're
trying to change with this
vision
thank you
representative samsich yes uh thank you
mr chairman
i have a question actually it's for miss
noonan
um from the previous section and it has
to do with uh
shopping for electric rates in the
competitive energy supply
i've always noticed as her diagrams have
shown
that the commercial industrial sector
has wholeheartedly embraced getting
their own
energy supplies at better rates than
they had before
um because they're at like 91 i think
was one of the numbers mentioned
but looking at residential customers um
of one one utility for example there was
only 18
of residents actually chose an energy
supplier
and i want to point out that every time
i talk to people about that
ordinary residents are very a very
cautious and mistrustful
of whether that's a good idea or not
when in fact they could get a good deal
and
could lower their electric rates
but they don't trust the system to be
reliable for that they just don't
understand it enough
has there been any effort made or bigger
effort made to try to let
residents know that they can be
confident when they choose a supplier
thank you for your question
certainly there's considerable
information on the commission's website
there's the shopping website that's
available
we get a lot of questions my team gets a
lot of questions from customers on how
competitive supply works
there certainly are if you're a
careful shopper and are willing to
spend the time to pay attention ways
that consumers can benefit
from competitive supply rates um
beyond that though the commission hasn't
undertaken
any other initiatives
um it is a competitive energy market and
i think it's
it's difficult for us as the regulator
to
to involve ourselves too deeply in it
well well i understand that but i mean
when once one has to understand that
commercial industrial businesses
have a whole team of people who work on
these issues for the company
and they can figure this out what the
best interest of the company is
would you suspend representative uh i'm
sorry
but we're not supposed to debate okay
we've got questions just
ask questions i'm sorry okay thank you
thank you very much
representative callie pitts i have one
more question and i believe it's for
amanda
when we look at at the ratios of
consumer
requests or complaints or
that you have can you
explain and and
i'm doing this for the benefit of the
new people at perhaps telephone
inquiries have gone down um
certain gas industries inquiries have
gone down
why those have bottomed out
sure no that's a that's a great question
um
and now i'm gonna wrap my brain and hope
i come up with the right thing
sometime um 2010-2012
the legislature uh
partially and almost completely
deregulated the telephone industry so
the commission's jurisdiction over
telephone companies is very limited at
this point in time
that's the primary driver behind the
decrease in calls related to telephone
that you see
we do still receive calls from customers
obviously
about telephone service um and we do
have escalation processes in place with
the telephone companies to get those
resolved for customers
we also do the same for wireless even
though that has never been regulated
but it is a great service for customers
to take advantage of
to help go around the roadblock so to
speak and get to somebody that can help
them with their issue
so that that's phone as far as gas
you see a spike for gas and i don't have
the chart in front of me but going by
memory again the spike in
gas calls is directly related to
um spike in overall energy prices uh
both electric
and gas prices and bills were very high
and escalating and so we had a number of
calls from customers
questioning that and then with
difficulty paying these high bills that
were unexpected
that was 2014 2015
polar vortex time frame for those who
might remember that
follow-up representative kelly pitts
no i want to just thank amanda you're
welcome
thank you representative vincent
don't forget to unmute yourself thank
you thank you uh mr chairman
and thank you mr moon for uh taking my
question
i do believe i know the answer but i
would like to have it put out because of
the
other new representatives
um so who owns the transmission lines
what transmission so i'm going to defer
that question to mr franz i believe he's
going to talk about that a little bit
later on in the presentation um
perhaps he could jump on now and and
answer your question
happy to jump on now thank you amanda
in new hampshire most of the
transmission is owned you can hear me
right
yeah most of the transmission is owned
by eversource
however obviously there's the
hydroquebec
dc line that comes down and goes into a
terminal in massachusetts and
then there's also some high voltage
lines owned by
uh what was is was
still in the name of new england power
transmission company
and those are 230 kb lines
for the most part next to the 450
kv dc line and eversource has
transmission lines ranging from 115 kv
up to 345 kb crossing the state
thank you very much for that um and
thank you
mr chairman thank you representative
representative samsich
no i'm sorry mr chairman i i i had my
question answered
okay thank you very much
back to our presentation
[Laughter]
hi uh i'm tom france director of the
electric division
i know many of you and many of you know
me uh
i've been with the commission well let's
just say for a long time
uh long enough to see the psnh
bankruptcy and reorganization back in
the late 80s early
90s 1990 um restructuring
of the industry and then through the
sale assets and purchase power
agreements
into the world of uh much more
distributed retail
customer oriented electricity that that
world that we're in today
electric division works closely with
other divisions
including the sustainable energy
division and the audit division and
safety division
as well as amanda's group and of course
legal
uh it's a heavy workload division
i think if you saw that you previous
slide
most of the a lot of the dockets most of
them were uh
electric dockets starting with d and a
lot of the investigations
the electric division works primarily on
rates whether those are
the big rate cases that get filed once
every two three four years
or the everyday filings that
come in with changes in certain aspects
of the tariff
or the default service filings that the
utilities make twice per year to change
that service that goes to customers who
choose not to go to a competitive
electric supplier we also
work on a number of planning aspects
associated with the lease cost plans
the energy efficiency resource standard
which
in one way or another the commission's
been
working on energy efficiency issues
since the
mid to late 1980s just to
give a little perspective there as well
as lease cost planning
uh even though it's evolved over time we
also look at reliability and vegetation
management
uh cost recovery associated with outages
on and on rates rates are us uh
just to give a little quick history
though for those who may not
uh remember the
psnh generation assets were
sold in 2017 and 18
in that range came out of the 2015
settlement agreement
and the so psnh no longer
eversource no longer owns generation it
does have
just a couple of purchase power
agreements one with the burgess biomass
power plant up in berlin and a
small amount of power purchased from the
lampster wind facility
but it's no longer the owner of the
hydro or fossil thermal units that
it had for all those years
and uh that sale
brought in about 258 million dollars
175 million from the thermal units about
83 million from the hydro units
uh it also created a fair amount of
stranded costs which
you see on eversource bill which we'll
get to
so uh just wanted to mention that as
as background and then we'll
jump into the new hampshire
numbers this is just a real high level
overview of the electricity
market industry and
franchise service territories in new
hampshire our utilities as well as the
five municipal electric companies that
we don't regulate and we have minimal
regulation of the new hampshire electric
co-op but
i believe this very slide is hanging in
the
stme conference room committee room
so it hasn't changed a lot over time we
still have four franchise electric
utilities
uh as amanda said electric distribution
companies
eversource is by far the largest of
those uh
depending on how you measure it
somewhere around 72 percent
of sales or customers
again or peak load and then of course
unitil which has uh areas in this
downs in the seacoast as well as over in
here in concord area and of course
liberty
which is which we also still know it's
granite state electric company
retail sales have been fairly constant
over the last several years and expected
to stay that way
so we can jump now to the next next
slide
i'll fly through these
my understanding is mr crease discussed
this at some length the revenue
requirement this is
at the heart of regulation if you looked
at a regulatory book or a commission
order or
way back almost even 100 years ago
you'd see something like this for
determining rates so at the very
basic level of rate making it's the
revenue requirement
and it's some form of of this although
there are variations over time and
you can get it talk about
performance-based rate making and
incentive rate making but
at the heart of what we do for setting
rates for utilities
is the revenue requirement based on the
actual prudently incurred
uh operating maintenance cost
depreciation amortization and a
fair rate of return uh
for the shareholder all right
quick look at what a typical bill looks
like for a residential customer this one
happens to be of
eversource uh for
somewhere around 625 kilowatt hours per
month which is
typical obviously varies by year by time
of
year summer time usage is much higher
but this is your average for the
per month for a typical residential
customer and as you can see
the energy portion this customer
we assume it's taking energy service
default service from
eversource eversource goes out to bid
twice per year for six months at a time
solicits power in the wholesale market
uh
we get anywhere you know from
several bidders to a number of bidders
for that slug of power
we also they also go out for commercial
and industrial as well as residential
and that price can vary depending on
the six month period if it's winter
that's usually a higher price
if it's uh we see lower prices in the
summer
when there's a lot more natural gas
availability and gas prices are
low into the fall
but this gives you a good idea of how
a typical customer's bill breaks out
transmission as commissioner bailey said
is a
significant component and one that's
increased quite a bit
over the last 10 15 20 years
probably dates me some but when i
started
transmission was a very very very small
amount of the overall bill
and generation the energy portion was by
far the largest sometimes
uh varying around between 65 and 70
percent
we've seen energy prices drop because of
natural gas prices falling
and and that's reflected in the default
service solicitations that we get
from uh wholesale
providers and uh that shows that we're
down in the
anywhere from six cents to seven and a
half cents per kilowatt hour now
and then the other components as i
mentioned strain and cost
obviously distribution is a significant
component and
the other pieces all right
next one please and this is just to give
an idea of how
these default service prices varied over
the last 10 years
so and ms noonan mentioned
the polar vortex that was quite
disruptive in the markets
because of the really cold weather and
and
the shortages of natural gas because
natural gas was going
under contract to retail and use
customers
that made it very difficult to provide
to the wholesale generators that run
natural gas combined cycle plants and
that drove up the price dramatically
in those cold vortex years
and had some lingering effect for a
while
um and what we see is a
pretty good seasonality in these rates
and i'll stop there and
quickly uh take some questions as i'm
sure we're
working through our time slot rather
rapidly here and we have
lots of other people to go
well i see no questions and no hands
raised so
we can continue on with the presentation
it is 11
45 so we're uh
we're moving quite deeply into the uh
the time we've allotted so let's
continue on
hello good afternoon i hope people can
hear me
yeah i see a few heads shaking good so
my name is uh karen crampton
and i am the director of the sustainable
energy division at the commission
and the sustainable energy division's
primary responsibility is administering
the renewable portfolio standard
and its associated programs
we're also responsible for ensuring
compliance
by the energy suppliers
and we also as amanda and tom have
stated
uh we work collaboratively with the
other divisions at the commission
on renewable energy related issues and
dockets and consumer inquiries
so with that i'm going to um my
presentation is
a little bit different than others so
far in that
i'm going to try to give a quick
overview
of the renewable portfolio standard
policy here in new hampshire
this policy is the state's renewable
energy policy
it was enacted in 2007
and it sets targets for renewable energy
generation here in the state
and it sets those targets as a percent
of total load
the purpose is stated in the statute
is that the rps will provide fuel
diversity
local fuels keeping energy dollars here
in the state
it will reduce exposure to fossil fuel
uh fluctuation in prices and
the renewable energy will encourage um
the employee
the i'm sorry it will encourage
the development of low emission
technologies
um which will provide environmental and
public health benefits
as of the end of last year we had
5 200 approximately
facilities certified in new hampshire as
eligible to participate
in the rps and almost
5 100 of those facilities were located
in new hampshire
when i say the word facility um what we
mean by that
is a solar array um a wind
uh a wind facility hydro facility
those types of technology so it's a it's
an energy generator
uh corrin next slide please
so with that this slide attempts to
illustrate how the rps works rps again
is the renewable portfolio standard
i'm going to start on the left hand side
top corner you'll see a blue circle
that says electricity suppliers the
electricity suppliers and that includes
both our distribution utilities which
are regulated at the commission
along with our competitive suppliers are
required
to meet compliance or comply
with the rps and the way they comply
is by purchasing
renewable energy certificates or making
alternative compliance payments
that are a certain percentage of their
electricity
load or their sales to end customers
so what happens on an annual basis is
electricity suppliers
like i said comply with the rps
if they make alternative compliance
payments because there aren't enough
wrecks available in the market
uh those alternative compliance payments
go into what we call the renewable
energy fund
that is the green circle located on the
bottom left
hand corner of the screen that fund
then encourages and is used to
incentivize
the development of new renewable energy
facilities in new hampshire
so that fund provides dollars or money
for
the administrative staff or the staff at
the commission
it provides funding into the residential
rebate
programs along with the low and moderate
income grant program
and it also provides funding for
commercial and industrial rebates
and grant programs when i refer to
commercial and industrial here
one thing that is often confusing is
that is
uh really a rate class designation so
commercial and industrial does include
um towns schools and those
types of entities so they participate in
our programs from
what we call a cni perspective
those uh newly
constructed and interconnected
generation units then create what we
call a renewable energy certificate
that renewable energy certificate
represents one
megawatt hour of renewable energy
generation
people those facility owners apply with
the commission
my staff reviews those applications per
our rules and then certifies those
facilities
once the facility is certified
they report their information
to the new england power pool
generation information system knee pool
gis
through what we call an independent
monitor so this is how we're ensuring
that
the energy produced that's being
reported
up to kneepool is accurate
kneepool then takes that generation
and does what we call mint rex
so for every megawatt hour of generation
knee pool will generate or mint one
wreck
that wreck is then through a market
mechanism
is then used by our suppliers to meet
their rps
requirements so you can see it's
somewhat circular
um because then those wrecks are used
for compliance if there aren't enough
reps again it goes into an acp
and we continue to to go around in that
that circle okay next slide please
so how does this all relate then that
that market mechanism how does that
relate
specifically to the rps uh this grant of
this grant i'm sorry the graph
shows uh our state requirements or our
targets for renewable energy
you'll see that we have five classes
here in new hampshire those are so those
are five different types of technologies
that each contribute to what's meeting
our overall target so we have
uh representative in blue class one
that's all new renewables and the
production of biodiesel
new renewables are things like uh again
new
onshore and offshore wind
methane not methane um new
hydro solar well not solar sorry
things like that um then we get into our
class one thermal
that is actually um the creation of
thermal energy
through renewable energy resources we
have class
2 which is specific to new solar
and then we have class 3 which is our
existing biomass facilities
and existing methane so class 1 would be
new methane
and class 3 is the existing and then
class 4 is our existing
small hydro
karin next slide please so as i
mentioned
these renewable generation facilities
will create
wrecks on an annual basis and then we um
look at the compliance annually and when
we talk about annually we are
talking about a calendar calendar year
in this situation
not a fiscal year so
um the the graph on the left hand side
shows uh how the different suppliers
energy suppliers have met
their compliance requirements
since 2008 the
total cost of compliance and the the
mechanism again for meeting compliance
is both
a combination of renewable energy
certificates
and alternative compliance payments so
in this graph
the the wrecks are represented in green
the blue is the alternative compliance
payment
so as you'll see most years we are
and most recently meeting most of our
obligations through these renewable
energy certificates
over on the right hand side
i'm showing the average rate
impact and this is something that we are
required to calculate and and provide
actually on the customers
electric bills um annually and
this is across the state so it is
important to know that we do not do this
calculation
per utility or per competitive supplier
this is taking the overall cost of the
rps
which again is the cost of the wrecks
that were purchased along with the
alternative compliance payments
dividing it by the total electricity
used within the state
to then give you that for example in
the .0061 cents per kilowatt hour so
that's
a little over a half a cent per kilowatt
hour
corrin next slide please
so that just looked at the total cost of
the rps
as i said there are two ways of meeting
that obligation one is through the
renewable energy certificates the other
is through alternative compliance
payments
the renewable portfolio standard
provides for a renewable energy fund
which is solely funded by the
alternative compliance payments
those alternative compliance payments as
i mentioned earlier are then used
for incentivizing projects
through grants and rebates so
the renewable energy fund is a dedicated
non-lapsing fund
again to support those renewable energy
initiatives
it is administered by the commission but
not continually appropriated
so that means that any unspent funds
that we have at the end of the year
do not carry forward into the next
fiscal year
corrine next slide please
so just to uh i highlight some of the
accomplishments of those grants and
rebate programs
um this chart provides you
uh information on our five rebate
programs
and this is a cumulative chart so it's
showing data
uh since around 2010 2011 when a lot of
these programs um
were begun but you can see overall we've
just paid out over 35 million dollars
worth of rebates to
new hampshire residents and businesses
towns municipalities schools and such
um those 35 million dollars worth of
rebates
have spurred total investment in
projects
of almost a quarter of a million dollar
yet quarter of a million dollars no
i'm sorry quarter of a billion dollars
222 million dollars
so we are seeing that that that
investment to expenditure ratio of
almost six to one so for every you know
dollar we
put into these rebates we're seeing
about six dollars of um of economic
development
through those projects
we've also just to give you some feel
for the amount of
um rebate applications and quantities
that are coming through
um we've you know paid out about 8 000
rebates
to date uh in fiscal year twenty uh we
paid out over a thousand rebates
uh korean next slide please
the other part of our work is grants uh
these are competitive grants that are
run
through requests for proposals at the
commission
our non-residential or cni grant program
has been in existence since 2011 it is a
statutorily required program
and as you'll see by the chart we've
awarded 43
grants to date valued with grant funding
at over 12 million dollars
spurring project development in excess
of 60 million dollars
the two graphs the two pie charts um
just show how that money's been spent
and as you can see on the left hand side
um the grand spy technology we've we've
given grants to geothermal
hydroelectric biomass projects solar
thermal
a landfill gas a variety of technologies
the the technologies that are are shaded
more in the orange
tones are our thermal type generation
versus the blues are electricity
generated generation projects
the graph over to the right or the pie
chart to the right
it just gives you a sense that you know
we're we're funding and providing grants
to both
private entities and public entities so
a lot of schools municipalities
wastewater treatment plans
have benefited from our grant program as
well as
um businesses
the other competitive grant that we we
run annually
is the low and moderate income solar
grant program
this uh program has only been in place
for three years
it was uh introduced uh through a bill
roughly three years ago
and to date we've awarded six projects
this is for community solar
those community solar projects provide
direct
benefit to over a hundred
low and moderate income families here in
new hampshire
and they're providing that benefit
without any upfront cost or ongoing
costs
so we're very proud of that program we
uh if you want to have more information
on it we did create a report
or publish file a report with the
commission that was again
required under the law that took a look
at
the types of projects that were being
funded and the types of benefits being
uh uh given to to those families
corrin next slide please
so that was a summary of um
the renewable portfolio standard how it
works
i hope it was helpful i know we get into
a lot of details and i'm happy to uh
as you're hearing bills uh dive a little
bit deeper into some of the areas that
uh
you'll be you'll be tackling this
legislative session
but i'd like to switch gears and and
talk a little bit about net metering
um the sustainable energy division
has worked very closely with the
electric division on
the net metering alternative the
alternative net metering docket
and we spend quite a lot of time working
with
consumers businesses and and such
understanding net metering to help them
understand that metering how it works
and how it's it works here specifically
for new hampshire
so at a very very high level this
picture and i did
take it off of eversource's website and
modify the words just slightly so i will
give them
credit um basically shows
a very simple net metering example where
you would have
solar panels for example on your house
or in a field
um those solar panels are directly
connected to an inverter that's that's
at your house or again in the field
as the sun hits the solar panels
electricity is generated
that generated electricity is either
used by the home
or business if if there is demand
if there is not enough demand for that
electricity
the electricity is sent out to the grid
that's where you're seeing those blue
arrows going up to the power lines
and if the
um if it's evening and the sun is or the
sun is not shining and there's not
electricity being generated
the gray area the gray arrows coming
from
the power pole is electricity coming
into the house
and really what's then happening on a
monthly
or shorter interval is that power going
out versus the power coming
in is quote unquote netted and the
customer's bill at the end of the month
of the
at the end of the billing cycle reflects
that
net energy consumed
so the other thing oops i'm sorry let me
just
not being able to see what my next slide
is i think i need to keep talking
here yes i do so the other thing that we
have here in new hampshire
um is what we call group net metering
and what group net metering allows is
for that
electricity that's being generated to be
shared
by multiple uh
meters or accounts within the same
distribution territory so this could be
for example like our low moderate income
solar program where there's a larger
array out in the field that excess
generation is then shared by
multiple households and that's what we
call group net metering
that sharing can be done in a number of
ways we have what we call traditional
group net metering
which is done um simply by what we're
calling the host or the owner
of the renewable generation renewable
facility
we're there then sharing the excess
generation with their what we're calling
members the other thing that was enacted
in rules were just implemented at the
commission
uh is what we are calling what
legislator legislature has enacted is on
bill credits
which allows that sharing of credits
monetary credits um by the utility
on each of the customers electric bills
the other thing that we have dealing
with net metering
is a an adder for um
solar specifically uh that meets
requirements
for low moderate income recipients
so you can get a an adder on top of the
general net metering rate
for that okay i think that was my high
level on that metering
uh current next slide please
and this is just a quick summary uh the
i would say one of the the
largest dockets that the division works
on is the alternative net metering
docket
um that was actually started a number of
years ago but through the commission
order there were a number of follow-up
um requirements that came out of that
order
so the alternative net metering docket
did set a new tariff for net metering
which is uh energy
well for small systems energy uh
transmission and 25 percent of
distribution for larger facilities over
100 kw
it the compensation rate remains at
simply the energy uh
but out of that docket we needed to
update that what we call the 900 rules
which are the rules behind
net metering uh so those rules have been
updated
to reflect the alternative net metering
tariff along with all
the group net metering uh changes that
have been made including the on bill
credit and the lmi adder and we also
uh did some updates just to some
miscellaneous technical items
the other thing that happened this past
year is the locational value of
distributed generation study was
completed and filed with the commission
you can find that on our website
it's quite a lengthy um report with a a
lot of detail in it
um and then we will be proceeding this
year
uh with the value of distributed energy
resources study
uh the commission did issue an rfp in
2020 and we are
working towards
getting that contract in with a
consultant
and that is the end of my presentation
thank you all i know it's
been a long morning for everybody i
appreciate uh
i appreciate your attention and look
forward to working with you uh during
the session
my hearty thanks to the public utilities
commission for a wonderful presentation
as usual and for their participation
uh here this morning as we've uh already
broached the noon hour we're going to
move directly to our next set of
presentations
which will be delivered by a consortium
of our utility state utility companies
and so i will turn the floor over to
the lead for that group who i believe is
donna gamache of eversource
ms gamache go ahead
can you hear me now i'm sorry
i'm sorry for you i can't believe i'm
that person
okay so um it is the noon hour and we
are standing between you and lunch
and you've already listened to a lot so
um we are going to move into our
presentation but i
promise you that there will be um items
that um there that we will skip because
you've already heard much of it so
thank you for the opportunity to listen
to all the uh state's electric and gas
utilities this
this afternoon we're anxious to see you
all in person and to meet the new
representatives on the committee in
person
so in the meantime today's presentation
is really intended to provide you with a
very high level overview of our
businesses
and it's important for all of you to get
this presentation because much of what
you do in this committee affects how we
provide
service to our customers so we hope that
when we're done today that
the slides that you'll have reviewed um
will help you recognize a few things and
that is that we make sure that we're in
tune with what our customers need from
us
um we strive for that every day but we
also work to make sure that you the
policy makers
have the information that you need as
you move forward with your work
and we hope that we can provide you the
practical experiences
of what our customers have and need
during your decision making so we will
all be speaking to different parts of
this presentation so hopefully it'll all
go smoothly and i cannot tell
if the slides are up yet or not but um
i do have the first slide
so if this i'm just gonna put them up
right now one second great
thank you
great um okay so
um the slide that i'm gonna be
referencing is the slide that has the
map
on it and uh so first off let me just
um thank you for the opportunity uh to
be before you today my name is donna
gamache for those of you who don't know
for the new members i'm the director of
governmental affairs for
eversource energy and um we ever
as you've heard before we are the
largest energy company in new hampshire
and we serve well over a half a million
electric customers
in 211 communities and over 70 percent
of new hampshire's electric customers
we have over you heard a little bit
about this before we have over a
thousand miles of transmission lines in
the state
and 14 000 miles of distribution lines
um and you know just transmission lines
are like the super highway for
electricity they move high voltage
electricity
over long distances quickly um uh
eversource is also the largest property
taxpayer in new hampshire
uh in 2020 we paid uh just over 92
million dollars in property taxes and
those taxes go not just to the
communities where we have customers but
also to those communities where we have
infrastructure
that allows us to connect our customers
we have uh also over 1100 employees
and uh 16 different work locations
throughout the state
and obviously we try to hit every corner
of the state
for the work as as well as with storms
but we also recently added some mobile
work centers that can be moved to an
area during a storm event
that is fitted with the latest
technology to ensure that we have a
swifter restoration so
with that i'm going to hand it over to
mark
good morning my name is mark dean i'm a
lawyer here in concord new hampshire
and i have the pleasure to serve as the
co-ops general counsel
and despite the appearance of the
headphones i'm not an
airline pilot on the side um
a brief overview and introduction to the
co-op especially for those of you who
may not be
familiar with it
obviously i'm not going to try to go
through every point on the slides but
uh the the map there you see the
different colored areas that's
all new hampshire electric co-op service
territory
the different colors are for the various
operational districts
that the co-op has it that map
maybe looks is a slight exaggeration
because
uh it looks like most of those are sort
of by
town and in many of those towns the
co-op may
serve only a small portion of the town
and psnh sorry eversource
or others might also be present
uh i guess the thing that i would like
to make sure i
leave with you about the co-op um
is from a phrase that i've done a lot of
work in
thailand and there's a phrase you
commonly hear there which is
same same but different and uh
and that's what the co-op is uh among
its uh
electric distribution company peers uh
we're
same same and that we own polls wires
transformers
have service centers linemen and
basically provide the services you'd
expect from an electric distribution
company
but we're different because we're owned
by the
consumers that purchase the electricity
uh the co-op was founded back in 1939
it's a not-for-profit electric co-op
owned by the members it serves
the members elect the co-ops board of
directors
we've got about 85 000 members
we're in 118 communities
we have a very different
customer slash member mix than some of
the other utilities
uh 40 are seasonal members and
87 are residential so it it
creates a different uh business dynamic
in
in some regards uh because of the fact
that the co-op
is uh member owned and member controlled
the legislature back in 2000
passed a law that allowed co-op members
to vote whether they wanted to
basically remain fully regulated like
the investor owned utilities as they had
been in the past
or adopt a substantially deregulated
status and and they did that and since
the co-op is not considered a public
utility within the context of most of
the new hampshire statutes concerning
puc regulations and requirements
so anytime if you're looking at a a
piece of legislation that deals with the
electric
utilities if you see that phrase usually
that's what how it works is that it will
be applicable to public utilities and
and uh so implicitly then it doesn't
apply to the co-op unless it's
there's a long phrase that gets tagged
in there about deregulated electric
co-ops and you'll
then you'll know they're talking about
us
the co-op is uh one of the things that
it does
participate in as part of puc regulation
is the statewide energy efficiency
programs and i'll be giving a little bit
of an overview of that later in the
presentation
the co-op also has uh energy efficiency
electric vehicle programs and similar
what we call
social and environmental responsibility
programs that
are not funded by the systems benefits
charge
that we advance
and the sort of next best thing for the
co-op it has recently
gotten involved in broadband expansion
it built two of the cares funded
projects
this over the last few months and uh
it is has won grants from the
fcc to extend high-speed fiber
through many of the communities that the
co-op serves
and so that under the name new hampshire
broadband will be something you'll be
seeing and hearing about so that you may
get the pleasure of having me come in
and testify on bills that aren't
necessarily electricity
related um
and with that unless there are any
questions i'll
move on to the next slide and let huck
montgomery talk about liberty
thanks mark uh so i
am really pleased to share with all of
you
for the first time i think today um the
big news
that uh liberty utilities is now simply
liberty and we've um turned over our
logo and our brand
to reflect uh more of our
values around clean energy
greener cleaner more sustainable energy
systems and
we're excited to see uh you know this
this new brand sort of starting to roll
out across all of
our footprints so you'll still see a mix
of some of the old
uh branding uh of liberty utilities um
with on our trucks and um some other
you know uh some other places where
you'll see that uh just because we're
you know if if that uh you know say
truck rap had been
um you know invested in recently we're
not gonna
sort of waste money uh on on the useful
life of that
that wrap we're gonna you know make sure
we're we're adhering to the
to the uh uh to our responsibility to
our customers to make sure
that they're getting good value but we
really think that the value add of this
new brand
is important because it symbolizes again
that that really
um central commitment that we have as a
utility to
to sustainable energy systems so i think
as most everybody here knows
liberty is the larger the two natural
gas utility
companies in the state of new hampshire
but also the smallest of
our electric utilities so we have a
service territory
in our on the gas side that's
illustrated here in blue and this really
runs up the the 93 corridor
really from nashua to uh to tilton and
everything in between that's really the
economic backbone of the state so we're
excited to uh continue to
you know grow and and be a part of the
you know the the economic engine of the
state of new hampshire
as the gas utility provider here also
we serve again on the electric side here
illustrated in
yellow the salem area the upper valley
area and the charlestown area so
that is our footprint and the unique
configuration
of of that footprint is what sets us
apart from
our uh our peers uh and so sometimes
when we will be
talking to you about our policy
priorities that will really be informed
by
uh by that footprint the way that uh our
uh
service territory is configured so um i
believe
there are several of you here on the
committee
who live and represent our electric
service territory
and uh also i know many of you who live
in our gas service territory so looking
forward to working with all of you
and very excited to see uh what we can
accomplish together
this session uh happy to take any
questions anybody may have
and looking forward to i think also
talking a little bit more about
natural gas as a commodity and a utility
provided commodity later in the deck
so for the time being i will turn it
over
to cat to talk about unitil
thank you huck good morning everybody um
it's very nice to see
some people interfaces and some some new
faces as well
as huck said i'm kat burke i'm the
director of government affairs for
unitil here in new hampshire
as well as in massachusetts and in maine
unitil was founded in 1984 as an
electric and natural gas company
here in new hampshire we are
headquartered here in new hampshire in
hampton
we have about 390 new hampshire
employees
and as you can see from the map we serve
about 77
000 electric customers mostly in the
capital region
and on the coast and we also serve about
35 000 natural gas customers
over on the seacoast region our
centralized customer service center is
in concord
of course all of those individuals are
remote right now for the most part but
that's where you would find our customer
service center during normal times
we have a centralized electric center
and a brand new facility over in exeter
and our centralized gas dispatch center
is in portsmouth
i'll keep this moving back to donna i
believe yes
so um i have some good news for you this
slide is just intended to um
share the basics of how we get and move
power to our customers but you've
already had that overview so
i think we can skip that one if you
don't mind okay so this slide
is basically the transformation of the
grid so historically the grid
has evolved to adapt to changing system
conditions and customer
expectations and this slide is intended
to just show you a snapshot
of how not only the system but our
customers needs have changed
when electricity was first introduced in
america utilities
weren't regulated and there were no
service territories and some of you may
have seen photos
of streets in the northeast where there
were multiple sets of poles and an
ugly massive wires and it was soon
decided that
that couldn't keep on so uh decided it
was decided that utilities would be
granted a service territory and without
uh
the customers within that service
territory to have the opportunity to
decide which utility he or she wanted
um the regulatory compact was created to
ensure that there's strict oversight of
a utilities operations and costs
the system at that time was real pretty
primitive
um but with the growth of the economies
around the region um and more sharing of
resources
uh new control systems were introduced
and then you know fast forward to 2003
the blackout of that year resulted in
some new federal enforceable standards
that resulted in the grid being planned
and built to improve
reliability that really was the
cornerstone of making
so many changes in transmission so you
may have noticed that shortly after that
time
there was what appeared to be a mass
clearing of transmission rights of way
and that blackout was the result
apparently
at least i think in my memory of a tree
in ohio that hit a line
and there are now clear requirements and
strict penalties for not keeping these
roads clear
so from the early days to today all of
the state's utilities have invested
in infrastructure that allows us to be
more sustainable
um anticipate the growth of our
customers and to expand automation and
to
accommodate the incorporation of our
customers connections so
these these investments will bring us to
the grid of the future which is the next
slide cat
this one i can be very very brief it's
uh that
it's just that today's grid looks very
different than it did
not that long ago we and all the
utilities are continuing to find ways to
be more automated and
one of the i'll get to uh get into a
little more detail later but
the automation one just one of the real
benefits of the automation
is we had 12 storms this summer
and some of them were worse than others
you know and many of you probably didn't
even feel that in
some in some cases we were able to
restore
40 000 customers in five minutes because
of that automation where that may have
taken us two days
just a few short years ago so the
automation is
really helpful it's helpful for many
other ways as well and it helps keep us
reliable
as much as possible and um what we're
trying to do is anticipate new
technologies coming in
anticipating what those costs would be
to make sure that our customers can
can take advantage of those technologies
in a way that's more cost effective so
there's a big focus for on our part at
what's going on
at not only at the state level but also
at the federal levels for that
next slide cat this is just a visual
of how the grid has changed um as we
look to the future
all of the utilities are in a really
good position to stay focused
on solutions that our customers want
with a focus
on any technology that's at our doorstep
and i just want to
be very clear here a utility is not in
the business
to test out technologies just hoping
that they're going to work or
hoping that they won't be too expensive
for the most part
we will work with those who are testing
them
but we it would be very rare that our
regulators would ever approve us moving
forward with a technology
that hasn't been warranted or hasn't
been proven
already so for an example
one of the things that we were lucky
enough to do in massachusetts is
on cape cod we we have a battery storage
uh system that we um installed there
because we found that the local
ecosystem was so sensitive that
a need for a new line that it was a
distribution line we needed two
distribution lines
and um the ecosystem was so sensitive
that we just couldn't do that
so we were able to move forward with
installing a battery storage system
there it's working really well there but
we're trying to learn from that here in
new hampshire so that by the time
um that that system has been in place so
while we can learn
better ways to do it and find a way to
do it a little more cost effectively
here in new hampshire
next slide this is
um this is really just this mic for the
most part my
i think i have one more slide but my
closing slide and it's just meant to
show that
not only have things changed in terms of
poles and wires and that kind of
kind of technology but traditional
fossil fuel power generators are
increasingly being retired throughout
new england and
we are always looking for ways to ensure
that our customers have the electricity
they need whenever they need it
you've heard a lot about expanding local
small renewable generation um
and that's there's a great place for
that what we think
that is in the best interest of our
customers is to have a balance
so that we have as much of that local
small renewable energy
generation but it's also backed up with
larger scale
clean affordable energy um so that they
both
they can put you know as one the prices
are going up the other one's putting
downward pressure on that so
our customers can have a clean reliable
system
that it is hopefully as cost effective
as possible and
even maybe in the whole region new
hampshire can be a uh an example
so we know that our customers want
clean energy and we want to be able to
give it to them
as you know uh maybe you don't know but
we like
other utilities we have are focused on a
target of being carbon neutral by 2020
20 30
but we feel that we can reach that goal
in a way that keeps an eye on our
customers rate
and as we move forward with more clean
energy options
we um we stay in touch with our
customers and they tell us
they want more clean energy but they
also want it to be as affordable as
possible
and that is something that we're very
focused on so with that i'll hand it
over to mark
great thank you donna uh so i have a few
slides here just to give
a quick overview of the
statewide energy efficiency programs
that apply to both the
distribution electric companies and the
and the gas companies and i know
that don crease the office of consumer
advocate
presented last week or so i wasn't there
but i imagine he talked about this
some bit so i won't go into too much
detail
so prior to 2002 each of the utilities
had annual filings that included some
measure of energy efficiency programs
that they would propose
and and operate over the upcoming
year uh in in 2002 that became a more
unified arrangement where all the
utilities
filed jointly work together to develop
uh programs in a way that is
both consistent statewide so consumers
uh if there's for example advertising of
programs it's more uniform so it's more
effective
and also allows for i think a more
efficient
administration of the programs
the energy efficiency programs i won't
go through all the
the numbers here uh but they're designed
to
reduce the amount of electricity that's
used in the state
that that will contribute to reducing
peak usage days it you it
those peak usage days can drive costs
that are spread over consumers for an
entire year
because whether it's in transmission or
in capacity
values these electric systems have to be
constructed to make sure they're
uh built to handle the largest load
that is historically experienced or
projected and so
when you push the peaks down you
decrease the demand for
new uh generation construction
and new transmission destruction
construction and those are if you'll
recall from the pie charts you saw
earlier the capacity energy
and transmission costs make up a
majority of the
costs of electric service in the in the
state of new hampshire
so we can go to the next slide
um the utilities jointly provide these
services
through the new hampshire saves brand
uh and uh they offer
services to customers both residential
and commercial customers in a variety of
ways
from providing audits to determine
what the needs are of individual
customers
to providing discounts uh
and rebates on lighting and appliances
heating systems cooling systems
and active demand reduction which
involves
either the controlled curtailment of
electric
consumption during certain periods or
education about the value of that for
consumers
or providing incentives for consumers to
voluntarily curtail
their consumption during peak hours
again the
the more that demand is reduced at
peak times of usage the
better the effects are on minimizing the
cost of both the energy
additional transmission requirements and
additional generation
construction requirements you can go to
the next slide
so the the energy efficiency programs
are funded primarily through the systems
benefits
charge which is roughly it's it's a
different percentage for each of the
utility but
i think from an earlier pie chart you
saw
uh when the commission was providing
information
it's about three to four percent of an
average bill
and that would include low-income
uh portion of the system benefits charge
as well
and that funding pro supports these
programs
that provide significant savings to
consumers on their
electric bills to the extent they take
advantage of those programs
has environmental benefits comfort
in your home benefits and
for those who participate and has
the uh cost-saving
advantages that i discussed earlier
about peaks etc
for all consumers whether they
participate
in the programs or not uh
these are programs that save money uh
they take
an extraordinary uh amount of effort
this
is uh when the commission was talking
about dockets
the dockets involved in the energy
efficiency programs
pretty much are on
on running and ongoing at all times uh
implementing developing and uh
evaluating the quality of these programs
is a major endeavor takes a lot of the
commission's time
and the utilities have significant
dedicated staffs
and resources to it
it's something that i know representing
new hampshire electric cooperative
we feel it's a very important part of
our
mission and we think
all of the other utilities that
participate feel the
same way and i think if there are
specific questions on that and if
they're technical i would probably call
on someone else to answer them we would
go to
cat thanks mark
um so i just wanted to take a moment to
highlight one of the
the great programs that the utilities
take part in and that's a comprehensive
vegetation management program so the the
gist of this program
is and just to make sure that we prevent
you know trees from interfering with
electric lines during normal conditions
and also during significant storming
events
we do that through a variety of ways um
the biggest way is probably through
cycle pruning which happens on a
five-year cycle
we also do a mid-cycle review of that
five-year cycle so about every two and a
half years where we're pre-planning for
the
the next cycle of pruning and just
identifying any issues that
may be coming up in that next five-year
period we also identify hazard tree
mitigation
through a storm resilience plan as well
so we're specifically looking for
any trees and the like that would
cause issues during a significant storm
event and we do have a forest
management manager who deals with these
issues and make sure that
we're up to speed on all of these
problems we also deal with sub
transmission maintenance which is
essentially just mowing uh rights of
ways but those are all just some
examples of how
the various utilities take part in
vegetation management
and again the goal of this is to to not
only you know ensure that we have
reliable service and customer
satisfaction but it also helps reducing
the overall cost of storm prep in the
future
and response while we are um dealing
with a significant event so these are
all preventative measures that we take
part in
and on on the storm event uh no i'll
take a moment to talk about the
emergency response that the utilities
take part in
so um many of you will frequently reach
out to us
um you know before storms or during
storms and as you know
all of the utilities take part in an
incident command structure or ics
that allows us to flexibly respond to
various storm and emergency events this
could be a significant snowstorm it
could be a wind event it could be a gas
emergency
um or the like and essentially what
happens is internally each company would
stand up this ics structure
uh depending on what kind of event there
is a certain individual within the
company would lead those
those groups of individuals who are
responsible for for various roles in the
company and would get them through that
event
so all employees uh specifically at
unitil do have a secondary storm role
from their
for their normal job so i can use myself
as an example
i'm unitil's director of government
affairs and when we have a storm
um situation or an emergency situation
where we
activate our incident command structure
i serve as liaison for the company
so that mostly involves communicating
with elected officials like yourselves
and regulators
uh in all three states with any kind of
public service announcements
uh answering specific questions on
outages um
directing them uh where they can report
that and the like so that's that's
how the storm rules work and the
utilities also take part in
annual system drills uh unitil we do
that on the gas
and electric side which is essentially a
full day scenario drill
where we would play out a certain event
and we would get everyone in the company
who would be impacted by that event to
to run that scenario and respond
appropriately
as you can imagine we do have a very
strong commitment to safe and timely
restorations but
we do have phases that we go through in
order to ensure that that we can get
there so the first phase is public
safety phase
if you had an event um like the one that
you can see in in the photo here
uh the first issue would be to make sure
that everyone treats
down wires as live wires if it was a gas
event it would be to you know evacuate
individuals
um before we can move to any kind of
damage assessment that is of course the
priority
damage assessment phase would would
include members of
the utilities going out and and you know
doing just that
assessing damage and deciding what tools
and resources they need in order to
move to the next phase which is
restoration process
many of you probably are aware of the
communications uh pre-event
during and post of a significant event
where um
sometimes the incident command structure
set up or even if it's just something
that we think is going to be
you know a complicated but not as
burdensome event if it's on a holiday
for example
christmas this past year we did send out
some psas and the like and um just to
prepare people for that particular event
so um we do work very closely with
municipalities and first responders
so that uh they're aware of any weather
events that we see coming up and we can
appropriately respond with them
i do communicate with elected officials
so um if
you're in unitil service territory
you'll likely receive emails from me
i'm just letting you know that we're
expecting some weather
how to follow us on social media how to
report outages
and then uh letting you know when the
event's sort of wrapping up
i think with that i'll turn it over to
huck
or sorry donna
that's okay uh this i i think you maybe
you've seen this differently in a
previous i think the puc probably talked
to you about the electric bill
components but
i'll be very brief because you've
already seen it but i think the most the
most important takeaway here
is that before restructuring of uh the
electric industry here in new hampshire
um customers got their bill and it had
one it just had how much per kilowatt
hour to get your service and that was it
now it's broken down a little bit more
and the top
the top component energy service
that is the one where you have the
choice to get your service from somebody
else or take
what we call default service if you
choose not if you choose not to choose
you can get default service from
eversource um and
our rates are expected to change um
february 1st
and i i don't know what that's going to
be
but um uh as of august 1st the current
rate structure that we're under right
now are to all in
cost of electricity right now is 18.614
cents per kilowatt hour
and the energy portion there is um 7.068
cents
that is the largest component of the
bill there are other components that
they move around all the time
and um i i think somebody before me
mentioned that transmission
the cost of transmission is increasing
on the bill right now
transmission is three um 3.011 cents
per kilowatt hour or about sixteen
percent of the current bill
um and uh in in some ways
the fact that it is increasing some
people don't like it but it's increasing
for a lot of different reasons
um much of new england the transmission
system
was um put in place and constructed
many many years ago and lots of the
system
needs to be upgraded so that all of all
of the states in new england has been
actively trying to upgrade their
transmission system and i think we're
coming to the end
of a lot of that but as was mentioned
before also
in order to make sure that the renewable
energy which
the the larger scale renewable energy
which is really essential to keeping the
system together
it's not something right in the middle
of a city or right in the middle where
the load is it's typically outside
and we need the transmission to try to
get it to where the sources of that
power where they want to take the power
are so i think that's all i would say on
this because you've already gone through
this once already and
and i'll move it on to i think this is
huck
great thanks donna so just want to
briefly talk about
natural gas as a utility rate regulated
commodity
because we spend so much time talking
about electricity
because obviously that you know every
single
family and business in new hampshire
relies on uh electric service hang on
someone is calling me whichever decline
um and uh fewer
uh but a really significant number do
rely on natural gas for
for energy service about 170 or so
thousand customers
um of liberties in unitils that um
our natural gas customers and and uh
that's growing but
um we uh we do think that the the role
of natural gas
as a rate regulated commodity in new
hampshire is
is really critically important um in
fact
i i was really pleased to hear our
consumer advocate don crease
um write in a column last year that
you know the provision of natural gas is
a rate regulated commodity
is quote compatible with bold climate
action we believe that as well
and we think that the greenhouse gas
emission
profile of natural gas in addition to
its affordability
really makes it a central piece of the
puzzle for
you know affordability and
sustainability in our energy system
uh very at a very high level in sort of
rough percentage numbers the
emissions profile the greenhouse gas
emission profile of
natural gas about 30 percent lower than
than fuel oil
which is the way that um plurality of
cust of homes and businesses in new
hampshire
get their heat is oil
and so uh being able to convert
customers from
fuel oil to conventional natural gas is
already a big boost um natural gas is
also cleaner than propane incrementally
so
but the big difference with propane is
propane is delivered by truck which has
its own emissions and safety
profile and whereas natural gas is the
safest energy
of the safest fuel that we have and
uh because it's delivered and
underground pipelines which we were
really diligently to maintain and ensure
that um that they're safe
so um the the emissions profile is
really key and uh we certainly hear a
lot about
the electrification of of building heat
and um
that is that there's definitely a role
for that there are
there is really great technology out
there uh especially
air source heat pumps which are able to
um
you know really add uh efficiency to
electric heat but
what we do know uh from a cost
standpoint
um and you see here these illustrative
numbers about the
sort of percentage difference per unit
of energy um
across the different uh for for thermal
energy
natural gas is a clear winner on
affordability
that's also the clear winner on uh on
emissions
including compared to air source heat
pumps and the reason for that really is
uh you know electricity to run an air
source heat pump is generated
primarily in new england by burning
natural gas
at a you know an efficiency heat rate of
somewhere in like
30 to 40 percent range whereas natural
gas
is delivered directly to ng's customers
for for thermal energy
uh and building heat or industrial
process needs um
the very lowest end of efficiency source
the lowest efficiency
oldest appliances would be 80 or so and
the um newer new appliances can reach
efficiencies
98 99 so you're really taking all of
that energy
uh potential energy in the fuel and
converting it into into heat
if you do that um so there we definitely
recognize that there's a role for air
source heat pumps
and especially for decarbonizing
the building heat sector where natural
gas is not available
again we were very pleased to see that
when consumer advocate mr crease
wrote again last year that uh in the
first instance air source pumps uh from
in terms of policies that ought to be
developed around this ought to be
targeted at converting
customers of who have oil or propane but
don't have access to utility natural gas
so that's really where that
policy situation is at the moment in
terms of you know the efficacy of air
source heat pumps as
a decarbonization solution and really
what we
uh uh as a company at liberty and i
believe unitil is
really uh also focused on this what
we're focusing on
is decarbonization of the gas
distribution system through
clean fuel and that takes two forms
really renewable natural gas which can
be produced from
landfills we have a landfill rng project
that we're
proposing now here in new hampshire the
bethlehem landfill
that's owned by casella and there are
other pathways as well in particular
turning woody biomass into methane
through a process called gasification
which is uh really attractive uh and
technically
uh you know available and ready to go
technology that
could potentially support our forest
products industry now that
the wood burning power plants in new
hampshire are no longer
operational so there are obviously
benefits
for emissions reduction of increasing
forestry and producing uh meaning
planting more trees
and cutting more trees to make stuff out
of it that is the most basic
type of carbon sequestration and so
we definitely think that the future of
rng production in northern new england
is uh is
a bright one and we're actively
exploring those potential
uh pathways now uh but in the long run
out to 2050 is uh you know sort of
a really broad goal that many
policymakers are aiming for
of uh reducing emissions from that zero
by 2050
um that you know we we expect uh and
most in the industry expect that green
hydrogen is going to be really central
to that
um the the technology is available today
it's simply electrolysis using clean
electricity
it's really no no more complicated uh at
a high level then you run a current
through water to split apart the h
from the o in water and you produce
hydrogen and oxygen
a hydrogen can be uh blended into
existing natural gas systems up to a
percentage without have without changing
over any sort of
components on the customer or the
distribution company end
and also a 100 hydrogen
thermal energy systems um are uh
being developed around the world right
now and particularly in europe that is
the preferred pathway for
building heat uh and industrial process
heat and the sort of last mile of
decarbonization for
sectors like heavy lift transportation
and industrial process which really
can't be electrified
so in places like northern new england
where the
weather is really cold the housing stock
is really old
especially in areas that are that are
urban uh
it's really the kind of thing that we
expect the uh
decarbonization through uh rng and
hydrogen to be both the lowest cost and
again
the the lowest emission solution for
decarbonizing
these sectors so we're very excited
about that we're continuing to
uh to develop actual proposals and
policy frameworks to decarbonize this
system
while at the same time continuing to
make sure that the customers who want
this um really low-cost uh and clean
conventional commodity
are able to do so so um with that i will
uh we'll
move on and hopefully if anybody has any
questions about
those topics you feel free to reach out
to me at
this info that we're putting in front of
you right now and i know everybody else
here
would also be more than happy to feel
your inquiries
and thank you so much for uh for the
opportunity to speak with you today we
can't wait to work with all of you
through the rest of the session thanks
thanks to all of you from all the
utilities for that uh
excellent presentation i see we do have
a at least one question
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman just a quick uh
comment for
donna gomash and a question uh first of
all i want to congratulate every source
for being awarded one of the best
uh utilities for energy efficiency and
secondly i'd like to ask her a little
bit
to explain their eversource's uh
goal of nets new carbon neutrality by
2030.
that's only 19 years from now that's a
pretty short period of time what are the
what are your plans to do that
well i wish i could answer that exactly
um
because the person who did that for us
spent three years of her life
pulling it together um how about this if
i promise getting you something and
writing from her
and how we're gonna how we're gonna meet
it
thank you very much
okay thank you are there any further
questions
for our panelists here this afternoon
okay representative partial yes will
this powerpoint be available to us at a
later date
i think we should um yes uh maybe we
could send it to the
uh committee email address so that you
would all receive it then
i'm happy to make sure that you all get
it thank you open thank you chair
the puc has already sent their slide
deck
to the members of the committee
and so you'll have all the information a
summary of all the information you've
seen here today
in your inbox very very shortly if not
if it's not already there any
additional questions
seeing none i would like to remind
everybody
that a week from today we will begin our
work
in earnest we'll have our first series
of public hearings
we start at nine o'clock in the morning
we plan to run all day long until
five o'clock in the afternoon we have
scheduled six public hearings
we will likely hold one or more
executive sessions during the day
as i previously indicated
we have been instructed to retain
all committee and commission bills for
this session year
because putting together a committee and
and holding
committee meetings is difficult right
now with our
uh space limitations in the legislative
office building and the state house
so we're being asked to put those bills
on hold
so we very likely will have executive
sessions to
vote to retain several bills
at our session next friday
i also want to remind everyone that
in order to vote at an executive session
you need to make arrangements to have
a video available
because myself as the chair
needs to be assured that the person
casting the vote
is who they say they are and so i need
to be able to see your vote your face
and i will need a a video
representation or you could come to the
meeting
in person and vote that way but
otherwise no telephone
voting will be allowed for exec sessions
and that's uh
per the speaker of the house so if there
are
any questions i see there are a couple
let's move to those uh representative
mcgee
don't forget to unmute representative
sorry thank you again mr chairman um
what you just mentioned about the
meeting in person is there
going is there going to be anyone
physically
there to run the meeting in person or
are you planning to be remote i'm just
curious because i'm
wondering if people are going to head
there and then there won't really be any
infrastructure in the room
i'm just curious uh the answer to that
question is they are setting up a room
for us
and some people will be there live i
can't tell you how many i have no idea
um but some people will choose to be
there
in person to conduct the meeting
others will choose to zoom in
as we're doing here with this meeting
that's your choice
um everybody can free be it should be
free to make the choice that
suits their situation the best right now
my plan
is to be there in person and i know a
few other
representatives who also plan to be
there in person but
um like i said it's your choice
did that answer your question it does
but the other thing i'm curious about is
if you're there physically in person
are you still going to have the
technology
so that we're all in one
place i don't understand how the hybrid
is going to work i guess that's what i'm
asking
yes those of us who are there live will
also be on camera
and we will also be able to see
everybody else
who is in the meeting via video
so do i know exactly how it's going to
work
no because next friday will be our first
shot at trying it but
um that that that's the plan i guess
there are a couple of committees that
will be meeting earlier in the week
next week they'll be using this
technology and
the system and we'll find out yeah
really work
or does it not you know
uh representative samsich i believe you
are next
yes thank you mr chairman uh i just
wanted to
kind of remind you that you you were
going to give us an opportunity to have
all the members introduce themselves to
each other
we really haven't done that so at some
point where you can make some time to do
that that would be appreciated
thank you for that reminder um
i suppose we could try it uh right
before we conclude this meeting uh
let me get to representative oxenom for
a question and then
maybe we could move to introductions
after that
i'm most unhappy about the directive
that we're not going to have
any committees or commissions i don't i
simply don't understand why we can't use
the format that we're using right now
to accomplish really important work uh
during the period june to december
i have several bills which now are just
going to be
removed from consideration
i i would like direction as to whether
it's worth my while to
present written testimony for a bill
that i'm now told
is not actually going to be considered
so uh
and i i don't see why we've scheduled
them for an hour
um i i'm throwing up my hands and asking
for a little bit more direction please
from the chair
okay well the reason i scheduled them
for an hour is so that we can introduce
the bill
uh allow some minimal testimony on it
just to get a sense of the bill
and then maybe recess the public hearing
go into executive session
and vote to retain the bill
and i suspect that it'll take pretty
much an hour to do all that
especially with the hybrid format
as far as your written testimony is
concerned
you'll get a chance to submit that
when we take the bill up in the fall
because
in the fall we have to take up our
retained bills
and uh decide what to do with them
before the house deadline for that which
i think is sometime around
the first of december the end of
november somewhere around there
uh you can look in the calendar and see
where when that is
but uh that will be the time
to to put forth all the
the testimony and the evidence that you
want to submit
to support the passage of the bill
does that make sense i thank you very
much for that clarification
and i i appreciate the notion that we
actually might be able to
do something in the fall
thank you i i think it's more than
that we might be able to do things
something i think will be compelled to
do something
in the fall so representative kelly
pitts
don't forget to unmute
where in a person is the room going to
be
set up for every representative
um will there be a mask requirement
and has parking been determined
yes to all three of those the room will
be set up to accommodate all members of
the committee it's a double room
uh it's my understanding that there will
be plexiglass
placed between the um
places that members would sit
so that in addition to being at least
six feet
apart from each other uh there will also
be a barrier between you
and the member to your left or to your
right
masks will be reco required
anytime you are moving so if you get up
and go out into the hallway to go to the
restroom or whatever
you have to wear a mask once you are uh
seated at your seat at the table in the
lob hearing room you will
be allowed to take off your mask
but once you get up and move around
again
you have to put it on and
and the rest of my question was has
parking been determined yet
yes there was a notice in the calendar
yesterday that said parking information
will be distributed
this week this week thank you for this
coming weekend
uh representative samsich
yes uh thank you mr chairman just to
clarify the issue with
uh committees and study committees um
is this a uniform decision that all
bills
that are requiring a commission or study
regardless of where they come from will
all be handled the same way
yes that is correct okay and basically
the reason for it is because
the president of the senate chuck morse
has told us that any study committee
bills that gets passed out of the house
will be killed by the senate okay
thank you we want it to survive we have
to return it thank you mr chairman
yes representative nader
[Music]
thank you mr chairman uh we may be
rethinking
the plexiglas because some information
came in
um that it may cause
you know the germs to just stick to it
and we'll be breathing it in and it
might not be as healthy as we
originally thought so that's not a
guarantee
that was what we uh talked about on
monday at a meeting
but then we were all supposed to be
meeting on on friday and
or monday and that got moved to friday
so things have changed but that's that's
what i know
so the situation is fluid we know that
um so thank you for that fresh
information which i had not
yet heard so
members should be aware of the fact that
there may not be plexiglass after all
even though that we were told that that
would happen uh
earlier looks like that may no longer be
the case so
be aware of that as you
weigh the uh the pros and cons
of appearing in person versus uh by a
zoom
representative oxenom did you have
another question
yes i did thank you um i understand that
you will
and um representative harrington will be
speaking before
the oca's ratepayer advisory committee
on monday
yeah could you share anything with us
about that
um i'll just share with you that the
consumer advocate invited us to appear
and we both said yes
no notion of about what they asked us to
make a short presentation about why we
signed the letter
asking for a
suspension of the docket uh
regarding the energy efficiency resource
standard
oh thank you very much
okay i see no further questions so let's
uh let's try to get to know each other a
little bit let's do some uh
let's do some intros um
oh now i see representative callie pitts
has her hand up i don't it's a mistake
oh okay trying to get it down in the in
that case
uh i'm gonna start with you introduce
yourself to the committee
i can't i can't get my hand down it's
stuck
um my name is representative jackie
kelly pitts i represent
portsmouth wards one two four and five
i've been on this particular committee
for 23 years so i've seen a lot been a
lot
heard a lot done a lot um
and that's about it
thank you representative callie pitts
uh i will go next i'm representative
michael vose
and i represent district 9 in rockingham
county which is the town of epping
i've i'm starting my fourth term in the
legislature
and i've served on the science
technology and energy committee
all three of my previous terms and
i'm looking forward to what i think will
be an exciting year for all of us
next on the list is representative
pimentel
hi my name is rod pimentel i'm
a retired not retired an ex-marine
i did my term back during the vietnam
era and uh got a
uh bs in uh
life science at the unh
and uh have been in the plumbing trade
for the last 40 years
the last 17 years was as a an hvac
systems designer
and uh currently retired have a wife
iris and three kids and five grandkids
um one thing is that
i was in the uh the edna the last term
this is my second term and we had a lot
of acronyms that we had to learn
um st e has
them be hands down and if there's anyone
out there who has
their little lists of acronyms on a
pdf or a word document
and would like to email them to me i
would greatly appreciate it
so thank you very much nice to meet you
all
nice to meet you and welcome to the
committee i can guarantee you that
uh a publication of acronyms that we use
in this committee would be the size of a
book
that's the way it is okay
next representative oxenum ah
okay i'm also starting my fourth term i
was one term on
uh rrnd and since then i've been on ste
i guess my science highlights i was
for about 10 years at the national
academy of sciences
when i concluded my career there i was a
study director
um i'm basically an economic policy
analyst
i've been an environmentalist since the
1960s and was
present in new york city at the first
earth day
um i think that's probably enough to be
going on with
and who do you represent oh worth
knowing yes
sullivan county district one i'm in
plainfield which is a little town
very close to lebanon on the connecticut
river
thank you next is representative jose
cambrie
thank you mr chairman uh my name is jose
campbells
i'm from merrimack county district 9
representing
canterbury and loudoun i'm a retired
executive engineer from bae systems
and i'm just so happy to be on this
committee it looks like it's loaded with
a lot of wonderful people
and thank you thank you and welcome
aboard
next let's move to representative
jacqueline
creation hi i'm
jacqueline kriesham you can call me
jackie i'm also
i represent manchester wards one two and
three
this is my second term in the
legislature last year i was on
environment and agriculture committee my
background is in the biosciences i have
a phd in molecular and cell biology
and i work at a company that helps
researchers get their work published so
i edit
science papers all day long in a variety
of fields mostly biology but
um some more relevant to this community
so you're not intimidated by acronyms
are you
i love acronyms the wackier the better
well welcome aboard next is
representative mcgee
thank you yes i'm i represent
hillsborough 27 which is hollis new
hampshire down on the border
and this is my second term on science
technology and energy
my professional background is i have a
masters in psychology
which i got many many years ago which
helped me in business
i moved into technology just at the
right time for someone my age or i would
have missed the boat completely
and i ended up being a program manager
in a software engineering firm
for e-learning so i have a technology
background
and i've learned that technology is
something that's you know in scarce
supply
even in the state bureaucracy so i feel
like it's kind of a good fit
um that i'm here at this time and that i
have that ability to sort of cross over
these worlds
um and i really enjoy this committee so
i'm
excited to be back with all of you and
to see our new members and welcome them
um so i guess that's probably all
i need to say about me oh there's only
one thing i wanted to say is i hope when
we do
our roll calls that we can get faster
because
um you know i think we can probably get
through it faster
especially where our meeting days are
going to be so long
so i just wanted to say that okay thank
you very much
you you forgot to mention your singing
career that's true
yeah i sang for 30 years i don't think
anymore
oh and i have uh four grown children
nine grandchildren and one
great-grandchild
wow yeah that's a lot
never stop singing okay
next is representative tom lozaz
hello i'm tom claudia i'm married
uh four kids three grandkids
been in uh ems for 40 years
did a 15 years with a union
worker is general motors
in another 15 years in uh
chemist chemistry analytical i'm your
hands-on technician making the numbers
for everyone
let's see um grew up in a
farming area right now as of last week
i'm just down to chickens
i think i'm gonna stay there for now um
so this is a freshman and i represent
bill knapp one
which is center harbor and new hampton
thank you okay welcome to the committee
next is representative jd bernardi
yes good afternoon folks uh jd bernardi
from southampton rep representing
rockingham 16 which is southampton east
kingston
and kensington i have an undergraduate
degree in biochemistry
was in the navy nuclear
submarine program for five years and
another uh
21 in the reserves um
i went to uh franklin pierce
law school after my act of navy service
and then joined uh new england nuclear
corporation
uh and got into the
pharmaceutical business uh been in
pharmaceutical development for
38 years uh and now i'm
just a consultant and have joined
your august company
okay welcome to st e
next is representative marshall
yes i am lucious partial i represent
marlboro
and troy and this is my first term prior
to this i've been a music educator in
new hampshire public schools for 20
years
and before that i worked in arts
administration working with
public radio and symphonies i did an
arts colony
i have a bachelor of music from ithaca
college
and an mba from suny binghamton and i've
had a few interesting jobs which i
talked about some other time and uh
let's see and i'm just delighted to be
on this i've been a lifelong
advocacy of trying to reduce my own
carbon footprint
so this is a personal interest of mine
thank you well welcome next we'll
uh turn to representative nick white
hi everyone i am uh nick white
i am married i represent uh pembroke uh
in chichester that's merrimack county
district 20.
um i am by day i am a solution architect
for a software company
that focuses on iot and connected
products
and i also have a variety of small
business startups that i've uh
i'm in the process of kind of spinning
up including
cleaning business hop farming um
a bunch of other random things and uh
i'm excited to be here uh oh and
and up until this last year uh uh
i've been uh primarily a network
engineer in
telecommunications and wireless
technology
well welcome we're glad to have you on
board next is representative peter
samsich
well thank you mr chairman uh i'm peter
samsich i represent district 27 in
portsmouth
uh this will be my third term in the
legislature
um i was born in budapest hungary
and during the 1956 hungarian uprising
my parents left
the country and came to america when i
was six
uh becoming citizens um
but subsequently after my father passed
away
uh in the u.s we moved back to uh europe
to germany
i got some of my education in the u.s
and
most of it in germany and it culminated
in
a phd for physics in the university of
heidelberg
but then i got hired by a european
company to come to new hampshire to
hudson
and uh subsequently worked for selenia
lighting for 34 years as a material
scientist
and one of my uh
my free time activities has been as
a caseworker for amnesty international
for 30 years
taking care of political prisoners so
i'm glad to be here and it seems like we
have a very
stellar group of people with good cr
credentials
thank you thank you representative
samsich next is representative mann
thank you mr chairman um i'm john mann i
represent uh
three small towns on the west coast um
alstead marlow and surry
cheshire district 2. i have some
experience and some successes in the
energy efficiency area and i'm
interested in that
i have had
spent about two four years in the navy
after graduating from college seemed to
be
sailing all over the place uh i was a
math teacher after that in high school
level
and i spent maybe six or eight years
combined and ibm and digital including
writing uh
um some software that
uh for ibm that ended up being a product
for p6
so that's and i'm old that's it for me
the dean of the committee welcome john
good to see you again
next is uh representative lex rezny
uh thank you mr chairman so i represent
grafton district 9 and this is my first
term
i was born in ukraine and immigrated to
the united states when i was about seven
my profession is software development
which i've done for about 20 years
i'm also a volunteer firefighter and
i look forward to serving on this
committee
mr chairman you were muted i just
realized that
uh welcome thanks we're glad to have you
here next is representative ken vincent
thank you mr chairman yes i'm kenneth
vincent
i represent uh district 17 which is five
and six in dover
and wards two in somersworth i am
starting my third term
um i was a uh
full-time firefighter uh slash
lieutenant
uh and the chief fire investigator uh
for the city of somerset for 33 years
and i need to tell you when i came to
this committee
i picked this committee because i wanted
something different than what i was
normally doing
and every one of these people that
you're looking at intimidated me
i'm not an attorney i'm not a physicist
i'm not
up there but what i am is a guy who
understands things
in common sense and
save lives for a while uh other than
that i'm married
um i have five grandchildren
um and two children or five children and
five grandchildren and i'm pretty happy
with this committee
um and i want to wish all of you uh
a lot of good luck because this
especially the the freshman because
there's a lot to learn in this and uh
i hardly know anything but i know enough
to be dangerous
thanks a lot for listening to me and
good luck to all of you
don't be intimidated
thank you mr dangerous and welcome again
to the committee
representative janine notter
hi everyone um i'm janine i'm
this is my sixth term my fourth term on
ste
i'm the house majority whip this term
my husband and i and our kids moved here
in 98.
we have six grown kids and grandbaby um
on the way she'll be here in april and
this came in the mail today while we
were
we were having our meeting this little
people
thing um
before politics i spent 10 years in the
world of fitness
i'm a long distance runner so as soon as
we're done here i'm hitting up visit the
streets with my dog and run around the
block several times
and i look forward to working with all
of you and intimidating my
former seat mate representative vincent
[Laughter]
welcome back to the committee janine
great to see you
representative douglas thomas yes hi
i go by doug and i'm uh
on my fourth term as is uh chairman
votes
all of them with the science and tech
committee i'm a graduate of hanover high
school
bs in plastics technology at a lowell
tech mba out of
montana university air force
and and air guard retiree and veteran
and spent the most of my civilian
work at hanscom air force base as a
acquisition
logistician and program manager
and i'm glad to be on this committee
again i'm glad to see we have a lot of
people
we do have i believe one of the most
stellar and technically
knowledgeable uh people on a committee
since i've been on it
and i'm looking forward to good and
robust discussion
oh and i represent rockingham five
londonderry
thank you representative thomas next is
representative rebecca william
mcwilliams
thank you chair bose my name is rebecca
mcwilliams this is my
daughter victoria sarah also known as
tori
um she's three months old so she may be
joining us for some of these hearings
that we have coming up because i am
working from home with her kind of on
and off during this crazy covert time
i represent the west side of concord
merrimack 27
i'm actually a mom of three i also have
three-year-old twins but they're
usually in daycare
as as a profession i am a
licensed architect and licensed attorney
i split my time about 75
25 attorney architect um i'm
self-employed which is how i'm able to
make this work
um and i do have quite a bit of
involvement with startups
so i would love to chat with um i'm
sorry i've missed i've lost your photo
but the representative who does startups
i'd love to chat about that
and my youngest brother is also a navy
nuke so
something else in common here and i'm
very excited to be back for my second
term on stne i think you guys are a
great group i'm looking forward to
working with you
thank you representative mick williams
you'll want to speak with representative
nick white about startup activity
next we'll uh touch base with
representative
susan hamola
hi i'm sue hamola i represent hollis uh
here at hillsborough district 27
alongside cat mcgee
i've actually been in the air force i
spent time as an air force meteorologist
and 20 plus years as a military spouse i
currently work
in the field of hazard mitigation
planning i actually work with
department of emergency management
writing a fema hazard mitigation plan so
like the person who spends all their
time editing documents that's what i do
all day actually
and i have four children and i'm very
happy to
be meeting all your acquaintances and
getting the opportunity to learn a lot
thank you so much thank you
representative from allah
i might add mr chair if i may uh
effective today i just got the notice
that
representative hamala is officially
assigned to the stne
at least until representative plett can
be fully
employed back on our committee good
okay thank you very much representative
thomas and welcome
representative amola and the last
place we have uh representative michael
harrington i hope you can uh
you can get fired up there michael and
uh
introduce yourself
star six to unmute
jen do you have to do anything to unmute
representative harrington
i'm not sure if representative
harrington is connected by telephone
anymore um he he had been connected by
computer to watch you guys
and connected by phone to participate um
and i'd no longer see his
telephone connection oh okay okay
all righty well then that uh you have to
hold up that baby
can't see it was there anyone else on
the call that
that i uh missed uh as far as an
introduction is concerned i think i got
everybody
okay well let's call it a day uh it's
we've run over our time by about a half
an hour
apparently zoom didn't cut us off so we
can be thankful for that
and uh i will look forward to seeing
everybody a week from today
at nine o'clock and thank you very much
for your participation today
and have a wonderful weekend thank you
thank you so much